and welcome to your second drink of business trip. This is the episode where Michael goes on a business trip with Oscar and Andy to Winnipeg. He meets concierge Marie. One of my favorite characters. Andy drunk dials Angela, one of my favorite scenes. And Pam finds out she's failed art school and has to stay another 12 weeks
欢迎收听第二杯“出差”特辑。在这一集中，迈克尔和奥斯卡、安迪一起去温尼伯出差。他遇到了礼宾员玛丽，她是我最喜欢的角色之一。安迪酒后给安吉拉打电话，这是我最喜欢的场景之一。帕姆发现她没能从艺术学校毕业，如果想真正毕业，她还得再待12周。
if she wants to really graduate. Oh. And we got to interview Rich Summer for this episode all about his arc as Pam's art school friend, in quotes, friend. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. And listen, we also recently did an interview with Wendy McClendon Covey about her
哦，我们还采访了里奇·萨默，聊了他作为帕姆艺术学校朋友（加引号的“朋友”）的戏份。嗯哼，嗯哼。听着，我们最近还采访了温迪·麦克伦登-考薇，聊了她
time as concierge Marie. It's episode 259, if you want to check it out. She's delightful. Yes. Well, I mentioned in our breakdown of this episode that there were some awesome deleted scenes specifically between Oscar and Andy. I talked all about
饰演礼宾员玛丽的时光。如果你想听的话，那是第259集。她非常可爱。是的。我在解析这一集时提到过，有一些很棒的删减片段，特别是奥斯卡和安迪之间的。我谈到了
Oscar being the fun stopper on the airplane, and I played a little clip. Well, you guys, All of the Oscar and Andy's stuff from the plane has been added back to the superfan version, including more that isn't even on the DVDs. I watched it. It's really great. And it really sets up the scene in the bar later because it's actually on the plane that Andy decides he's going to be Oscar's wingman.
奥斯卡在飞机上是个“扫兴鬼”，我还放了一小段剪辑。好吧，伙计们，所有奥斯卡和安迪在飞机上的戏份都被加回了超级粉丝版，甚至包括DVD里都没有的内容。我看了，真的很棒。它为后来酒吧里的场景做了很好的铺垫，因为正是因为在飞机上，安迪才决定要当奥斯卡的僚机。
Yeah. In fact, there's this whole scene on the plane where he tries to set him up with the guy sitting in the window seat of their row. Yes. And speaking of this storyline, when we ask people their favorite moment from this episode, we got this letter from Carrie J. and Omaha who said, one of my favorite scenes from the whole series is Oscar in the bar with Andy trying to be his wingman.
是的。事实上，飞机上还有一整段戏，他试图撮合奥斯卡和坐在他们那一排靠窗座位的男人。没错。说到这个情节，当我们问大家这一集中他们最喜欢的时刻时，我们收到了来自奥马哈的凯莉·J的来信，她说：“我最喜欢的全剧场景之一就是奥斯卡在酒吧里，安迪试图当他的僚机。”
I love how Oscar plays the part like absolute perfect acting by Oscar. And everyone, the scene is also the scene with the drunk dial to Angela. I really think we need to hear it. If you don't mind me asking. Anything. You can ask me anything. Okay. I'm your wingman.
我喜欢奥斯卡演那个角色的方式，简直是完美的演技。各位，这一幕也是安迪酒后给安吉拉打电话的那一幕。我觉得我们真的需要听听。如果你不介意我问的话。什么都可以。你可以问我任何事。好吧。我是你的僚机。
It's just that I've sat next to Angela for a very long, very long time. Right-do. How can anyone stand that woman? What? What are you seeing her? What do you see in Angela? What I see in Angela? I don't want to know.
只是我和安吉拉坐在一起很久，非常久了。对。怎么会有人受得了那个女人？什么？你在看她？你在安吉拉身上看到了什么？我在安吉拉身上看到了什么？我不想知道。
I see through a hard exterior to a little jelly in the middle. She is teaching me to be a better person. She's working really hard on that. And she's the softest skin I've ever seen. I can't wait to have sex with her. You haven't had sex? No. Are you guys waiting to get married?
我透过她坚硬的外表，看到了内心的一点柔软。她正在教我做一个更好的人。她在这方面非常努力。而且她的皮肤是我见过最柔软的。我迫不及待想和她发生关系了。你们还没发生过关系？没有。你们是在等结婚吗？
Or? Honestly, I don't know what we're waiting for. Andy, something is wrong with that woman. What is wrong with her? I'd like to know you should call her and ask her. I'd like to know what's wrong with her. I should call her and ask her. Do it.
还是？老实说，我不知道我们在等什么。安迪，那个女人有问题。她有什么问题？我想知道，你应该打电话问问她。我想知道她有什么问题。我应该打电话问她。打吧。
It's a caller. Oh my God, no call her. It's no calling. Too late. Too late. It's silent. Now it's ringing. Hello? Hello?
是个电话。天哪，别打。别打。太晚了。太晚了。静音了。现在在响了。喂？喂？
What is wrong with you? Why would you do Andy? What? That's Oscar, and he wants to know why you won't do me, and I think it's a valid question. Are you drunk? This is Andy Bernard. I know who this is. I want to take a sex school.
你有什么毛病？你为什么要这么做，安迪？什么？那是奥斯卡，他想知道你为什么不跟我做，我觉得这是一个合理的问题。你喝醉了吗？我是安迪·伯纳德。我知道你是谁。我想进行性教育。
What? Who is that monkey? There's somebody there. Are you drunk? I have needs. We will discuss this later. Naked. What?
什么？那只猴子是谁？那里有人。你喝醉了吗？我有需求。我们稍后再讨论这个。裸体。什么？
We'll discuss it later, naked. I want to see you naked. It is such the perfect drunk dial. It really is. And the two of them together, it's delicious. It's chef's kiss. I agree with you, Carrie, Jay. It's fantastic.
我们稍后再讨论，裸体。我想看你裸体。这真是完美的酒后电话。确实如此。他们俩在一起，真是太美妙了。简直是神来之笔。我同意你的看法，凯莉·J。太精彩了。
And Ed played that moment so great. Because, you know, being drunk isn't easy to play. And I loved it when he was like, it's Andy Bernard. I just like, I know who it is. I also love it when, you know, Oscar blurts out, Andy wants to know why you won't do him. And you're like, what? And you think maybe Andy is going to cover then, right? Like he's going to be like, no, no, no, no. He meant he, nothing. He just repeats it. So good. Yeah. Well, listen, there were so many great things added back to the super fan version of this episode, including this very funny scene where Michael, before they go to Winnipeg, he's at the airport and he's changing money at one of those.
埃德演得太棒了。因为你知道，演醉酒并不容易。我喜欢他说“我是安迪·伯纳德”的时候，我就想，我知道是谁。我也喜欢奥斯卡脱口而出“安迪想知道你为什么不跟他做”的时候。你当时想，什么？你以为安迪会掩饰，对吧？比如他会说，不不不，他不是那个意思。但他只是重复了一遍。太棒了。是的。好吧，听着，这一集的超级粉丝版加回了很多精彩内容，包括这一段非常有趣的场景：迈克尔在去温尼伯之前，在机场的一个柜台换钱。
Kiosks? Mm-hmm. You have to hear it. What is the heart of the Canadian economy? Money. And I am getting some. Thank you very much. Hold on.
售货亭？嗯哼。你得听听。加拿大经济的核心是什么？钱。我正要换一些。非常感谢。等等。
Michael, how much money did you change? Two grand, baby. Oh, no. We're only there for one night. Oh, look at the commission rate. And there's a handling fee. Okay. All right, all right.
迈克尔，你换了多少钱？两千块，宝贝。哦，不。我们只待一晚。哦，看看这个佣金率。还有手续费。好吧。好了，好了。
Chill out. Quick fix. Excuse me. Change it back. Yes, yes, yes, yes. Get as much as you can. Strippers do not take credit cards. Change it back.
冷静点。快速解决。打扰一下。换回来。是是是是。换尽可能多的。脱衣舞女不收信用卡。换回来。
Change it back. Why are you still changing money? Michael, you don't need cash. You get a better rate on the credit card. You only need cash for the cab ride. Do you understand? I'll see you at the gate. Change it back.
换回来。你为什么还在换钱？迈克尔，你不需要现金。信用卡汇率更好。你只需要现金付车费。你明白吗？我在登机口等你。换回来。
Change it back. This is a smaller pile. That? Okay. now I've $1,800. It's amazing. He's lost money before they've even, like, done anything. He just stood there and just paid $200 to change his money back and forth.
换回来。这堆钱变小了。那个？好吧。现在我有1800美元了。太神奇了。他还没开始干什么，钱就亏了。他就在那儿站着，花了200美元把钱换来换去。
I know. So good. And the person that plays the attendant is so put out with him. It's really funny. Yes, they're very funny. There was also a little bit of an old tech alert in there, too, because now everyone pays in a cab with, like, their credit card. Oh, this is true. There's no like cash transaction cabs anymore.
我知道。太棒了。那个柜台服务员对他很不耐烦。真的很有趣。是的，他们很有趣。里面还有一个小小的“旧技术警报”，因为现在每个人坐出租车都用信用卡支付了。哦，这是真的。再也没有那种现金交易的出租车了。
No, you just use your credit card or Venmo or whatever. It's so true. Well, we also got this letter from Caroline K from Dublin, and it really made me chuckle. Caroline says, Hi, ladies, hope you are both keeping well. Just an observation, Michael brought two huge empty suitcases to fill with souvenirs, but no sign of them on the way back. Maybe they had checked them in already. It reminded me of when I worked for a dessert company and once had to travel from Dublin to Edinburgh
不，你只是用信用卡或Venmo什么的。太对了。好吧，我们还收到了来自都柏林的卡罗琳·K的来信，这真的让我笑了。卡罗琳说：“嗨，女士们，希望你们都好。只是一个观察，迈克尔带了两个巨大的空手提箱去装纪念品，但回来时却没看到它们。也许他们已经托运了。这让我想起我曾在一家甜点公司工作，有一次不得不从都柏林去爱丁堡
with some frozen dessert samples. The little case was full on the way over. We had our meeting and presented the samples to the client and then the suitcases were empty coming home. I got stopped at security because they thought it was suspicious to be traveling with an empty case. I could only laugh trying to explain my situation. They were grand about it in the end. So this was reminding me of how whenever we go on like a big long family trip, we never anticipate that we're going to buy anything on that trip and we pack our suitcases totally full. And then we're scrambling and we have to buy like some duffel bag or something. Yeah, some random bag to bring your your souvenirs back. Yes.
带着一些冷冻甜点样品。那个小箱子去的时候是满的。我们开了会，向客户展示了样品，然后回家时手提箱就空了。我在安检处被拦住了，因为他们觉得带着空箱子旅行很可疑。我只能笑着解释我的情况。最后他们对此表示理解。所以这让我想起，每当我们进行一次长途家庭旅行时，我们从没想过会在旅途中买任何东西，我们把手提箱塞得满满的。然后我们就会手忙脚乱，不得不买个行李袋之类的。是的，随便买个包把纪念品带回来。是的。
So I think it was very smart of Michael to bring the two empty suitcases. Well, I wanted to round out this second drink with this letter from Soyan from South Korea, who writes us all the time. I know, Soyan, you're lovely. Thank you. Lovely. And I really especially loved this letter. And it has to do with this episode. Here's what So Jan had to say. I've wanted to write this message for a long time because I loved that Pam gave up on art school. I know some people might say that decision wasn't very feminist, but honestly it has given me tremendous comfort. In most sitcoms or dramas, when a protagonist makes a big career decision, everything works out in the end and they become very successful. But the office is different. It let Pam fail. And that's okay. Life goes on anyway. Even when you fail in your work, it's okay. What matters is remembering that you tried. It's not your fault and you are still loved by your friends and family. Right now, I'm pursuing my own dream and it's a tough road. At the end of it, I might fail. But that's okay. I believe I will still find meaning and joy in my life one way or
所以我认为迈克尔带两个空手提箱是非常明智的。好吧，我想用这封来自韩国的Soyan的信来结束这第二杯特辑，她经常给我们写信。我知道，Soyan，你很可爱。谢谢。可爱。我特别喜欢这封信。它和这一集有关。Soyan是这么说的：“我想写这封信很久了，因为我喜欢帕姆放弃艺术学校。我知道有些人可能会说那个决定不太女权，但老实说，它给了我巨大的安慰。在大多数情景喜剧或电视剧中，当主角做出重大的职业决定时，一切最终都会好起来，他们会变得非常成功。但《办公室》不同。它让帕姆失败了。这没关系。生活还是要继续。即使你在工作中失败了，也没关系。重要的是记住你尝试过。这不是你的错，你仍然被你的朋友和家人所爱。现在，我正在追求自己的梦想，这是一条艰难的路。最后，我可能会失败。但没关系。我相信我仍然会以这样或那样的方式在生活中找到意义和快乐，就像帕姆一样。爱你们，女士们。”
or the other, just like Pam did. Love you, ladies. That is fantastic. Isn't that great? It's just so great and so true. So true. I mean, how many things did we fail at before we got on the office, lady? So many. And all of those things were worthwhile. They always led to a new friendship, or maybe like just enough money to pay the rent that month or something. Like, everything I've tried in my life has not been a huge success. But there's value in the trying. Isn't it great? I loved that letter. I loved that point of view for this episode. Same. Well, you guys, thank you so much for writing in. And now, please enjoy our second drink of business trip. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office
那太棒了。那不是很棒吗？真是太棒了，太真实了。太真实了。我的意思是，在加入《办公室》之前，我们失败了多少次，女士们？太多次了。所有这些经历都是值得的。它们总是带来新的友谊，或者也许只是刚好够付那个月的房租之类的。就像，我一生中尝试过的每一件事并不都是巨大的成功。但尝试本身就有价值。这不是很棒吗？我喜欢那封信。我喜欢这一集的那种观点。我也是。好吧，伙计们，非常感谢你们的来信。现在，请享受我们的第二杯“出差”特辑。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在做终极《办公室》
Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Oh, hi, you guys. All right, today we're talking about business trip. Mm-hmm. But first, we have a fantastic interview for you. Yes, we are going to be talking with Rich Summer.
重温播客，专为你准备。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。哦，嗨，伙计们。好了，今天我们要聊的是“出差”。嗯哼。但首先，我们为你准备了一次精彩的采访。是的，我们将与里奇·萨默交谈。
Who played Alex? Art School Alex. I know. We love Rich. We're good friends with Rich in real life. Yes, my stepson and Rich's daughter B are in a book club. You guys, they meet every week. It's the cutest thing. It's the cutest thing.
他饰演了亚历克斯？艺术学校的亚历克斯。我知道。我们爱里奇。我们在现实生活中和里奇是好朋友。是的，我的继子和里奇的女儿B在一个读书俱乐部。伙计们，他们每周都见面。这是最可爱的事情。这是最可爱的事情。
You might know Rich Summer because he played Harry Crane on all seven seasons of Mad Men. And at that same time, he was doing his arc on the office as Pam's art school friend. Friend? Question mark. And Jenna and Rich spent a ton of time together filming all those scenes and became really good friends. We did. We just had to talk to him. We wanted to hear his side of the story of filming that crazy.
你可能认识里奇·萨默，因为他在《广告狂人》的所有七季中饰演了哈里·克莱恩。与此同时，他还在《办公室》中饰演了帕姆的艺术学校朋友。朋友？问号。珍娜和里奇花了很多时间一起拍摄那些场景，并成为了非常好的朋友。我们确实是。我们必须和他谈谈。我们想听听他拍摄那个疯狂场景的侧面故事。
scene with the little Bluetooth ear pieces from customer survey. We talked about it last week with Stephen Merchant. Yeah, we needed Rich's take on that. We really did. And we talk all things the office for Alex. And here is that interview. Rich Summer, welcome to office ladies. Hi, Rich. Thank you. Hi, Angela and Jenna. Oh my gosh, when we post the photo from this interview, Rich looks so professional. I can't believe you're saying that. I am in a teeny tiny box. I just have a wide angle camera.
就是那个来自“客户调查”的蓝牙耳机场景。我们上周和斯蒂芬·莫昌特谈过。是的，我们需要里奇的看法。我们确实需要。我们聊了所有关于亚历克斯在《办公室》的事情。这就是那次采访。里奇·萨默，欢迎来到《办公室》女士播客。嗨，里奇。谢谢。嗨，安吉拉和珍娜。天哪，当我们发布这次采访的照片时，里奇看起来太专业了。我不敢相信你在这么说。我是在一个极小的盒子里。我只是有一个广角摄像头。
It makes it look cool. I know, but you have the stuff that looks like egg carton. You know what I mean? You have like the real deal sound stuff. That's $10 at a foam place in Burbank that I went to. Jenna should be able to be able to use of us. We probably should have gone there.
这让它看起来很酷。我知道，但你有看起来像蛋托的东西。你知道我的意思吗？你有那种真正的专业录音设备。那是我在伯班克的一家泡沫店花10美元买的。珍娜应该能用上我们。我们可能应该去那儿。
Gone there. Will you text us about it later when we get done? Yes. will. I also want to share that as we were setting up this Zoom, my microphone broke. So I'm using a backup microphone. So I probably sound the worst of all of us. Rich is going to sound the best. You look the most professional. Rich is what matters. You're what matters, Rich. We're here for you. We're excited to talk to you. We are. Rich, we always ask everyone on the show how they got their job on the office. Did you audition for the part? Do you have a story? We have heard that
去那儿。我们结束后你会发短信告诉我们吗？是的，我会的。我还想分享一下，当我们设置这个Zoom时，我的麦克风坏了。所以我用的是备用麦克风。所以我听起来可能是我们中最差的。里奇听起来会是最好的。你看起来最专业。里奇才是重点。里奇，你才是重点。我们是为你而来的。我们很高兴和你交谈。我们是。里奇，我们总是问节目里的每个人他们是如何得到《办公室》的工作的。你试镜了这个角色吗？你有什么故事吗？我们听说
Mindy was lobbying very hard for you. Did you know Mindy? To my recollection, Mindy and I met at the SAG Awards when you guys and the Mad Men cast were nominated. And Mindy was a fan of Mad Men and came up to me. And I was so excited to meet her. And we had chatted maybe a couple of times. But she came up to me and said, hey, I'm writing a part with you in mind on the show. Would that be okay if I was like, yes?
明迪为你游说得很厉害。你认识明迪吗？据我回忆，明迪和我在演员工会奖上见过面，当时你们和《广告狂人》的剧组都被提名了。明迪是《广告狂人》的粉丝，她走过来找我。我见到她非常兴奋。我们可能聊过几次。但她走过来对我说，嘿，我正在写一个角色，心里想的是你。如果我说是，那可以吗？
Because, you know, like everybody else, the office was one of my favorite shows on TV. So it was a really exciting thing to have, you know, an actor, writer, producer from another show, any show say that to you. But to have it be one of your favorite shows that you are so excited to even step into that world. It was incredibly special. Yes. That is so cool. So is that what happened? They just offered you the role after she had written it?
因为，你知道，像其他人一样，《办公室》是我电视上最喜欢的节目之一。所以，有一个来自另一部剧（任何剧）的演员、编剧、制片人对你说这种话，是一件非常令人兴奋的事情。但如果那是你最喜欢的节目之一，你甚至非常兴奋能踏入那个世界，那就特别特别了。是的。那太酷了。所以这就是发生的事情吗？她在写完之后就直接给了你这个角色？
Yeah. They reached out and offered it. And I had a friend of mine who I hadn't told him yet about that. And he said, oh, I just auditioned for the office. And I was like, oh, that's awesome. I'm hoping to audition for them as well. And he said, yeah, it's for this part. I guess Pam goes to art school.
是的。他们联系并提供了这个角色。我有一个朋友，我还没告诉他这件事。他说，哦，我刚试镜了《办公室》。我说，哦，那太棒了。我希望也能去试镜。他说，是的，是这个角色。我想帕姆要去艺术学校了。
And she's going to meet some guy at art school. And I was like, uh-huh. Oh, good, good, good. And in my head, I knew what Mindy had said. And we hadn't finalized anything yet. And you know how these things work in the business. they'll keep auditioning, even if they have an offer out to someone or in conversation with someone, they'll keep auditioning other people. I'm usually on the auditioning end of that where I'm throwing an audition down a hole rather than being the one that's actually being considered. But this was one of those rare times. So as soon as the offer came through officially, I was, I accepted immediately. But yes, it was, I did audition for the office a time or two with Allison Jones. But I, I was, I was, I did audition for the office a time or two. But I, I was. I, I did audition for the office, but I, I didn't get those roles.
她会在艺术学校遇到一个男人。我说，嗯哼。哦，好，好，好。在我脑海里，我知道明迪说了什么。我们还没敲定任何事情。你知道生意场上这些事是怎么运作的。他们会继续试镜，即使他们已经向某人发出了邀请或正在与某人商谈，他们也会继续试镜其他人。我通常是试镜的那一方，我是在把试镜扔进一个洞里，而不是那个真正被考虑的人。但这确实是罕见的几次之一。所以一旦邀请正式发出，我就立刻接受了。但是是的，我确实试镜过《办公室》一两次，和艾莉森·琼斯一起。但我确实试镜过《办公室》一两次。但我确实试镜过《办公室》，但我没得到那些角色。
And then this came through and it was just an offer. Well, Rich, you mentioned that you met Mindy at a SIG Awards party. Something people should know, I guess, is just that the cast of the office and the cast of Mad Men, we kind of glommed on to each other. We were on the rise at the same time. And we were kind of experiencing the same thing of being both casts that were basically unknown actors. suddenly on these really popular shows. And so we would go around to all of these events together,
然后这个机会来了，直接就是邀请。好吧，里奇，你提到你在演员工会奖派对上遇到了明迪。我想人们应该知道的一点是，《办公室》的剧组和《广告狂人》的剧组，我们有点粘在一起了。我们同时崛起。我们经历着同样的事情，都是基本上默默无闻的演员，突然出现在这些非常受欢迎的节目中。所以我们会一起去参加所有这些活动，
and we all became really good friends. It was a really sort of spectacular, odd marriage between the shows, because we ended up, like you say, our groups, because the way the SAG Awards work in particular is the entire cast of each show is seated together at one or two tables, depending on the size of the group. And then at the party, there's usually like, there's this corner for Mad Men and this area for the office. And every show sort of has an area.
我们都成了非常好的朋友。这在两部剧之间是一种非常壮观、奇怪的联姻，因为我们最终，就像你说的，我们的群体，因为演员工会奖的运作方式，每部剧的整个剧组都坐在一起，在一两张桌子上，取决于人数。然后在派对上，通常会有《广告狂人》的角落和《办公室》的区域。每部剧都有一个区域。
And our areas often ended up being near each other and at least ended up being sort of shared real estate. It was a very, it was a very cool relationship between the groups. Yeah. Some of my favorite memories from that time are our casts hanging together. It was really cool. I remember people watching at the madmen party. There was a madman after party. And Oscar Nunez and I sat on a couch.
我们的区域最终往往离得很近，至少最终成了某种共享的领地。两组人之间的关系非常酷。是的。我那个时期最喜欢的一些记忆就是我们剧组聚在一起。真的很酷。我记得在《广告狂人》派对上观察人们。有一个《广告狂人》的会后派对。奥斯卡·努涅斯和我坐在沙发上。
And we were sidebarring as everyone walked by. We're like, look at this guy. Look at this guy on. Those madmen after parties sometimes, I mean, every show has sort of the people that you're always like, I can't believe they watch our show. And I know you guys had that too. It was very strange times. I'm curious, what were you told about the role of Alex before you came in?
当每个人走过时，我们在旁边窃窃私语。我们说，看那个家伙。看那个家伙。那些《广告狂人》的会后派对有时，我的意思是，每部剧都有那种你总是觉得“我不敢相信他们看我们的剧”的人。我知道你们也有过。那是很奇怪的时光。我很好奇，在你来之前，关于亚历克斯这个角色，你被告知了什么？
Did you get anything to read? And were you told specifically that you were an art school friend or you were a possible love interest? How was this role pitched to you? Well, this is going to be, this is, this is the meaty part of the conversation, I suppose. I, the way it was pitched to me was, you know, this was the beginning of season five, obviously. And the way it was pitched to me was that it would be a, now, I should also clarify, especially if Mindy is listening. I'm not saying that Mindy pitched me anything. It was conversational.
你有什么要读的吗？你被明确告知你是艺术学校的朋友，还是一个可能的恋爱对象？这个角色是怎么向你推销的？好吧，这将会是，这是对话中实质性的部分，我想。向我推销的方式是，你知道，这显然是第五季的开始。向我推销的方式是，它将是一个，现在，我也应该澄清一下，特别是如果明迪在听的话。我不是说明迪向我推销了什么。这是对话式的。
It was just sort of like, we think this is a character who's going to be throughout this season. We think it's a character that's going to be kind of like Rashida's character was where it might be a little bit of another road bump for Jim and Pam. So when it started, that was definitely what was in my mind. But we filmed scenes that didn't make it into the show. And I started to kind of put together that the response from the audience were so, because your show, how long in advance did you guys shoot and then air? I would say only three to four weeks, maybe.
这只是像，我们认为这是一个会在这一季中出现的角色。我们认为这是一个会像拉什达的角色那样的角色，可能会成为吉姆和帕姆的另一个障碍。所以当它开始时，这绝对是我脑海里的想法。但我们拍摄了一些没有进入正片的场景。我开始有点拼凑出观众的反应是如此，因为你们的剧，你们提前多久拍摄然后播出？我想只有三到四周，也许。
There was a pretty tight turnaround. It felt really tight. Yeah. Yeah. It was enough time, or a short enough time, I should say, that the audience response to my first appearance was, had landed before I was filming customer survey. And they were not pleased. They did not want to see Pam like with anyone. But Jim, oh, man.
周转时间非常紧。感觉真的很紧。是的。是的。时间足够短，或者说足够短，观众对我第一次露面的反应在拍摄“客户调查”之前就已经落地了。他们很不高兴。他们不想看到帕姆和任何人在一起。但吉姆，哦，天哪。
No, and who could blame them? after what they had been through for, you know, four seasons, who could blame them? I know. Well, you have very kind of flirty eyes in your first scenes at art school. You're very flirty. And you're right. Those scenes aired. And all of a sudden, Tiki Bar is on the cutting room floor, right?
不，谁能怪他们呢？在他们经历了（你知道）四季之后，谁能怪他们呢？我知道。好吧，你在艺术学校的最初场景里有非常调情的眼神。你非常调情。你是对的。那些场景播出了。突然之间，Tiki Bar就在剪辑室的地板上了，对吧？
There is a whole Alex storyline with Pam. Actually, the whole Pam art storyline isn't deleted scenes. I watched the deleted scenes for the podcast. And every week, I'm like, Jenna, oh, my gosh, there's this scene and this scene and one in the hallway and at a bar and here. And she's like, I know. How did it feel to watch those scenes get cut week to week? Did anyone warn you? As far as how it felt, look, I am very, I consider myself fortunate that I have a fairly, I don't know, a comfortable ability to.
有一个完整的亚历克斯和帕姆的情节。事实上，整个帕姆艺术情节都在删减片段里。我为播客看了删减片段。每周，我都说，珍娜，天哪，有这个场景和那个场景，走廊里有一个，酒吧里有一个，这里有一个。她说，我知道。看着这些场景每周被剪掉是什么感觉？有人警告过你吗？至于感觉如何，看，我非常幸运，我认为我有一个相当，我不知道，舒适的能力去。
to see where things fit in story-wise. And I could feel from the moment we were, the second anybody said, this feels weird, this is too much, too much consternation for Jim and Pam, I agreed. I mean, again, I was a fan from the beginning. Now, I would have loved to have gotten to be around more, but I also wasn't going to be greedy.
去看看事情在故事中是如何契合的。从那一刻起，只要有人说，这感觉很奇怪，这太多了，对吉姆和帕姆来说太多的焦虑了，我就同意了。我的意思是，再说一次，我从一开始就是粉丝。现在，我本来很乐意有更多机会出现，但我也不想贪心。
I was, I remained delighted that I had the parts that I had. I do think it's a funny part of office lore because it seems clear to me, at least, that this was a sort of aborted storyline, that they kind of cut bait when they could. And that was, I don't know, I just think it's, how I feel about it is that it's a very funny, interesting way to have been a part of the office legacy. Well, I was bummed that you never came to the actual set because we never got to hang. out on set. And you and Jenna would have stories. And we were missing Jenna. You know, Jenna was who I had lunch with every day. And I was like, gosh, why can't Alex just, you know, show up with Bam at work one day? Of course, that would have completely like blown up the storyline. But we were sad. You were never in the actual bullpen. Should we talk about this insane scene that
我仍然很高兴我拥有了那些戏份。我确实认为这是《办公室》传说中一个有趣的部分，因为对我来说，至少很清楚，这是一个某种被放弃的情节，他们尽可能地止损了。而且那是，我不知道，我只是觉得，我对它的感觉是，这是一种非常有趣、有趣的方式来成为《办公室》遗产的一部分。好吧，我很沮丧你从来没有来到真正的片场，因为我们从来没有在片场一起玩过。你和珍娜会有故事。我们想念珍娜。你知道，珍娜是我每天一起吃午饭的人。我就想，天哪，为什么亚历克斯不能（你知道）有一天和帕姆一起出现在工作场所？当然，那会完全炸掉情节。但我们很难过。你从来没有在真正的办公区。我们应该谈谈这个疯狂的场景吗？
we filmed for customer survey with Stephen Merchant? First of all, did you crap your pants when You found out Stephen Merchant was directing? Because I did. I did poop myself. Yep. Yep. Yes. Yeah, it was upsetting. I mean, it was a 10% exciting, 90% up there.
我们为“客户调查”和斯蒂芬·莫昌特拍摄的？首先，当你发现斯蒂芬·莫昌特在导演时，你拉裤子了吗？因为我拉了。我确实拉了。是的。是的。是的，这很令人不安。我的意思是，那是10%的兴奋，90%的紧张。
I had no idea, Rich, how many different ways you guys did this scene. You know, we got the scripts and all the alts from James Carey, and I could not believe it. Jenna told me, how many different versions were there, Jenna? I think there were something like 10. Good night. Now, I wasn't privy to all of those versions because as a guest actor, I was really only given the script on the day. This is how I remember it. And I've listened to you guys talk about it with Stephen.
我不知道，里奇，你们用多少种不同的方式拍了这个场景。你知道，我们从詹姆斯·凯里那里得到了剧本和所有的替代方案，我简直不敢相信。珍娜告诉我，有多少个不同的版本，珍娜？我想大约有10个。晚安。现在，我并没有参与所有这些版本，因为作为客串演员，我真的只是在当天才拿到剧本。这就是我记忆中的样子。我听过你们和斯蒂芬谈论它。
And my memory is slightly different, but I don't know where it goes off. I've certainly mulled over this aspect of the story a thousand times. So it's probably gotten altered as I've gone. but here was my problem. My problem was that I had an inside, I had a mole on the inside, and I don't know if I've ever even told you guys about this. Wait, I won't name this person on the podcast.
我的记忆略有不同，但我不知道它在哪里偏离了。我当然已经把故事的这个方面思考了一千遍。所以它可能在我进行的过程中被改变了。但这就是我的问题。我的问题是，我有一个内线，我有一个内鬼，我不知道我是否甚至告诉过你们这件事。等等，我不会在播客上说出这个人的名字。
You had a mole on the set of the office? I won't, I won't name this person on the podcast, but this was a person who was not an actor who worked in the production, and this person sent me the script. He said, oh, you've got some great stuff in this. coming episode. It's a guy.
你在《办公室》片场有内鬼？我不会，我不会在播客上说出这个人的名字，但这是一个不是演员的人，他在制作组工作，这个人把剧本发给了我。他说，哦，你在这一集中有一些很棒的内容。是个男人。
Oh, my God. I loved. Shit. Yeah. Okay, fine. Yes, it's a guy. So this person sent me the script. And I was in that version, Alex professed his love to Pam.
哦，天哪。我爱。该死。好吧，好吧。是的，是个男人。所以这个人把剧本发给了我。在那个版本里，亚历克斯向帕姆表白了他的爱。
And I thought, oh, wow. And as a, it left it open, is this a send-off for my character? Or is this something that we may see him later on? I showed up on the day I was handed the sides. and those sides were, as you guys know, wildly different, that they had taken out any profession of love at all, made it purely about her sort of artistic sensibilities, and changed how that was going to go.
我想，哦，哇。作为一个，它留下了悬念，这是我角色的送别吗？还是我们以后可能会看到他？我当天出现时，被交给了台词。那些台词，正如你们所知，截然不同，他们去掉了任何爱的表白，使它纯粹关于她某种艺术敏感性，并改变了事情的走向。
So when we were filming, I will admit this is a fault of mine as an actor. I couldn't get it out of my head. Because, again, everything we had been playing so far was that Alex had a crush on Pam. And like you guys said with Stephen, what Alex ends up saying is enough. It didn't need to be this on the nose sort of profession of love.
所以当我们拍摄时，我承认这是我作为演员的一个缺点。我无法把它从脑海中抹去。因为，再说一次，我们到目前为止所演的一切都是亚历克斯暗恋帕姆。就像你们和斯蒂芬说的那样，亚历克斯最终说的话就足够了。不需要这种直白的爱的表白。
It's implied, it's intrinsic. As Jim says, you know, this guy's into you. I mean, it's clearly there. But in the moment, I couldn't find the right level of demonstrative that Stephen wanted. the level that Stephen wanted was zero. And the level that I was continually pumping out was more in the neighborhood of like 75% demonstrative. I couldn't reel it in. And in fact, Jenna, to your question of pooping my pants when I found out it was Stephen Merchant,
它是隐含的，它是内在的。正如吉姆所说，你知道，这家伙看上你了。我的意思是，它显然在那里。但在那一刻，我找不到斯蒂芬想要的正确程度的表达。斯蒂芬想要的程度是零。而我一直在泵出的程度更接近75%的表达。我无法控制它。事实上，珍娜，对于你关于我发现是斯蒂芬·莫昌特时拉裤子的问题，
that was just a little, that was just like a little jitter compared to how I felt when Stephen came up to me after a take and said these words. the words that have haunted me as an actor forever. He came up to me and said, I don't know why you're not getting this. Oh, no. It was awful. Oh, my God. He was, by the way, 100% right.
那只是一个小小的，那只是一个小小的紧张，相比于斯蒂芬在一条拍摄后走到我面前说这些话时我的感觉。那些作为演员永远困扰我的话。他走到我面前说，我不知道你为什么不明白这一点。哦，不。太糟糕了。哦，天哪。顺便说一句，他是100%正确的。
I just couldn't do it. So, you know, looking at Jenna Fisher standing across me, John Krasinski is crumpled up into a ball under the table in that room, reading his lines. for the Bluetooth. He was there. John was there? I remember he was there, but I didn't remember he was hiding under the table. Oh my God. Through all the takes? There was nowhere for him to hide in the room because it was a small conference room. And the cameras, as you guys know, were moving all the time. Everywhere. There was no safe space. So he just hid under the test. Six foot three,
我只是做不到。所以，你知道，看着珍娜·费舍尔站在我对面，约翰·卡拉辛斯基在那个房间的桌子下蜷缩成一个球，读着他的台词。为了蓝牙。他在那里。约翰在那里？我记得他在那里，但我没记得他躲在桌子下。哦，天哪。所有的拍摄过程中？房间里没有他躲藏的地方，因为那是一个小的会议室。而且摄像机，正如你们所知，一直在移动。到处都是。没有安全空间。所以他只是躲在桌子下。六英尺三英寸，
John Krasinski was curled up under the desk. Yes. And I'm just, I'm just, just like mortified. I'm like, this is the, well, this is it. I'm never acting again, obviously, because Stephen Merchant's never going to cast me in anything. Jenna and John think I'm absolutely out of my mind. It was, it was a stressful day. It's all great now, but it was a stressful day. Oh my gosh. Rich, I think you're being too hard on yourself and taking on too much of the responsibility because I was also told that Alex might be a possible love. interest for Pam, not that Pam would have feelings for Alex, but that she might have to manage his feelings for her. And by the way, I want to say, I only respected Rich in that moment,
约翰·卡拉辛斯基蜷缩在桌子下。是的。我只是，我只是，只是感到羞愧。我想，这是，好吧，就是这样。我再也不会演戏了，显然，因为斯蒂芬·莫昌特永远不会再让我演任何东西了。珍娜和约翰认为我完全疯了。那是一个压力很大的一天。现在一切都很好，但那是一个压力很大的一天。哦，天哪。里奇，我觉得你对自己太苛刻了，承担了太多的责任，因为我也被告知亚历克斯可能是帕姆的一个可能的恋爱对象，不是说帕姆会对亚历克斯有感觉，而是她可能不得不处理他对她的感觉。顺便说一句，我想说，我那一刻只尊重里奇，
and so much so that we went on to do a movie together. We did the giant mechanical man. You played my brother-in-law, and you were so funny. That's right. Giant Mechanical Man is a great movie, by the way. Great. And you guys are fantastic in it. It's a, I love that movie. And I, believe me, when I, in the, in the month or so following my final day at the office, and we had exchanged information because we, you know, it was clear we were going to be friends. I, my recollection is when you and Lee reached out to ask if I would come and do a table read for this movie that you guys were working on, it was both, So exciting, but also such a relief that you had not written me off after that day.
以至于我们后来一起拍了一部电影。我们拍了《巨人机械人》。你演了我的姐夫，你太搞笑了。没错。顺便说一句，《巨人机械人》是一部很棒的电影。很棒。你们在里面表现得太棒了。我爱那部电影。而且，相信我，当我在我《办公室》最后一天后的一个月左右，我们交换了信息，因为我们（你知道）很清楚我们会成为朋友。我的回忆是，当你和李联系问我是否愿意来为你们正在制作的这部电影做剧本朗读时，这既令人兴奋，也是一种解脱，因为在那一天之后，你们没有把我写掉。
Because it was just such a stressful, you know, you've had those days on a set where you feel like this is my last day on a set. I'm never acting again. Obviously, I'm garbage. I don't know why I did this. And usually I don't leave a day feeling that way. It's usually somewhere closer to the middle. But that day I left and I was just like, oh, that is that. That was that. I hope Mad Men goes forever because this door has been closed. So it was such a relief.
因为那只是一个压力很大，（你知道）你在片场有过那些日子，你觉得这是我在片场的最后一天。我再也不会演戏了。显然，我是垃圾。我不知道我为什么要这样做。通常我不会带着那种感觉离开一天。通常它更接近中间。但那天我离开了，我只是想，哦，就是这样。就是那样。我希望《广告狂人》永远持续下去，因为这扇门已经关上了。所以这真是一种解脱。
No one felt like that. Everybody thought that you crushed it. Really and truly. I thought I was rooting for Alex and I know I'm not. I wasn't rooting. What? No, listen. Listen now. So I don't get hate mail. I wasn't rooting for Jim and Pam to break up. But I became like I thought Alex was so endearing that I just. I want Alex to have a good life. I became that person. Like, I hope Alex finds his person because he's so sweet and kind. And I don't know. Rich, I have to ask, how did the set of the office and the way we shot and the way things worked differ from the way you guys made Mad Men? I mean, the ways we are similar is a very short list.
没有人有那种感觉。每个人都认为你表现得太棒了。真的，真的。我以为我在为亚历克斯加油，我知道我不是。我没有加油。什么？不，听着。现在听着。所以我不会收到仇恨邮件。我不是在为吉姆和帕姆分手加油。但我变得像，我觉得亚历克斯太可爱了，以至于我只是。我希望亚历克斯有一个美好的生活。我变成了那样的人。就像，我希望亚历克斯找到他的人，因为他太甜美和善良了。我不知道。里奇，我必须问，片场和我们拍摄的方式以及事情运作的方式，与你们制作《广告狂人》的方式有什么不同？我的意思是，我们相似的方式是一个很短的列表。
the Madman set, filming style, was entirely different. First off, for the first three, maybe four seasons of Madman, we were still shooting on film. So at this time, when I was doing the office, we were definitely shooting on film. And that, you know, for anyone who's been on a set where they're filming with film, it's a whole other process.
《广告狂人》的片场，拍摄风格，完全不同。首先，对于《广告狂人》的前三季，也许四季，我们仍然在用胶片拍摄。所以在这个时候，当我做《办公室》时，我们绝对是在用胶片拍摄。而且那，（你知道）对于任何在用胶片拍摄的片场的人来说，这是一个完全不同的过程。
It adds a remarkable amount of, time when you're even just changing a film mag, you know, a bit, the, the cartridge of film, it has to be sort of taken to a dark place and dealt with so that it can be sent off for processing. And it, the turnarounds on scenes, you know, moving the camera around takes, I don't know, not twice as long, but a lot longer. So the fact that on the office, they would hit roll and almost never stop until they were out of tape as a lot longer. I recall, right? I mean, it just, it felt like we were always rolling. Yes. It did feel that way. Yeah. You could kind of stop mid-scene if you needed to and adjust something, whereas on Mad Men,
它增加了一个显著的，时间，当你甚至只是在更换胶片盒时，（你知道）一点，胶片的弹夹，它必须被带到一个黑暗的地方处理，以便它可以被送去处理。而且，场景的周转，（你知道）移动摄像机需要，我不知道，不是两倍长，但长得多。所以事实上在《办公室》里，他们会按下录制，几乎从不停止，直到磁带用完，这长得多。我记得，对吧？我的意思是，感觉我们一直在录制。是的。确实感觉是那样。是的。如果你需要的话，你可以中途停止场景并调整一些东西，而在《广告狂人》上，
it was more, if we're filming, everything has to be in order. And if we're, if we cut, then everybody can breathe again. It was just a very different type of precision that they were doing on Mad Men because it was obviously the look is not handheld. The look on Mad Men was very carefully and intentionally composed. Not that shots weren't composed on the office, but it was just composed in a different way. It was much more fluid. We're watching the show now with our daughter.
更多的是，如果我们正在拍摄，一切都必须井然有序。如果我们切断，那么每个人都可以再次呼吸。这只是《广告狂人》上他们正在做的一种非常不同类型的精确度，因为显然外观不是手持的。在《广告狂人》上的外观是非常仔细和有意构图的。不是说《办公室》上的镜头没有构图，但它只是以不同的方式构图。它更流畅。我们现在和我们的女儿一起看这部剧。
She's 13 and she's never seen it. We're probably three quarters of the way through season two. Now, she knows, just because it's in the zeitgeist, that Pam and Jim end up together. it is driving her bananas. And I haven't even thought to say, if you think this is tough, wait until Rashida Jones shows up because she's just frustrated that, you know,
她13岁，从来没看过。我们可能看了第二季的四分之三。现在，她知道，仅仅因为它在时代精神中，帕姆和吉姆最终在一起了。这让她发疯。我甚至还没想到要说，如果你觉得这很难，等到拉什达·琼斯出现，因为她只是感到沮丧，（你知道）
Roy set a date for the wedding and Jim was sad. And B was like, this is terrible. When do they get together? I can't stand it. I'm like, buckle in. I got news for you. It's going to be a minute. Rich, she's going to hate you when she gets to your part.
罗伊定了一个婚礼日期，吉姆很伤心。B说，这太糟糕了。他们什么时候在一起？我受不了了。我说，系好安全带。我有消息告诉你。还要一会儿。里奇，当她看到你那部分时，她会恨你的。
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. What's that going to? What's breakfast going to be like at your house? Well, she has been with me when I have been recognized from the office. Oh, yeah. We were going to ask, do you get recognized as Alex? I do.
哦，是的。哦，是的。那会是什么？你家早餐会是什么样？好吧，当我在《办公室》被认出来时，她和我在一起。哦，是的。我们想问，你会被认作亚历克斯吗？我会。
And it is amazing to me how often, because sometimes, you know, as actors, we get different people recognize us from different things. And truly, it's got to be. half the time. It's the office. I mean, I'm on screen for two episodes of the office. So its reach was just sort of astounding to me. But I did, my favorite one is when Beatrice was a baby. She, I don't even think was a year old. We went to visit my family in Ohio. And we were getting on a connecting flight in Cincinnati. I'm walking my tiny, beautiful little baby girl down the aisle. And this guy leans into the aisle. And he goes, hey, hey. And I sort of.
而且这让我感到惊讶，因为有时，（你知道）作为演员，我们被不同的人从不同的事情中认出来。而且真的，一定是。一半的时间。是《办公室》。我的意思是，我在《办公室》的两集里出现在屏幕上。所以它的影响力对我来说简直令人震惊。但我确实，我最喜欢的一次是比阿特丽斯还是个婴儿的时候。她，我甚至不认为有一岁大。我们去俄亥俄州看望我的家人。我们在辛辛那提转机。我推着我娇小、美丽的宝贝女儿走在过道上。这个家伙探进过道。他说，嘿，嘿。我有点。
start and look, I'm like, yeah. This stranger says don't F with Pam and Jim. Oh, my God. And he meant it, by the way. So I think people, it was in those kinds of moments where I went, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. This is, it's better that Alex goes quietly into the night and they go back to their thing so that I don't, you know,
吓一跳，看着，我说，是的。这个陌生人说，别和帕姆和吉姆搞鬼。哦，天哪。顺便说一句，他是认真的。所以我认为人们，就是在那种时刻，我去了，哦，是的，是的，是的，是的。这是，最好让亚历克斯安静地走进黑夜，他们回到他们的事情，这样我就不会，（你知道）
get kidnapped or anything. Oh, Rich. Well, you know, maybe Alex had to go away, but we're glad you got to stay in our lives. Yes. And Rich, thank you so much for coming on the podcast today. It was so great to see you. Yeah. Thank you.
被绑架什么的。哦，里奇。好吧，你知道，也许亚历克斯不得不离开，但我们很高兴你能留在我们的生活中。是的。里奇，非常感谢你今天来到播客。见到你真是太好了。是的。谢谢。
Thank you so much for letting me be a part of this. Oh, my gosh. I'm just, I'm excited that we got to have you on the show. I'm excited we got to take that trip down memory lane. Hopefully this has been healing. I hope it's been healing. Yes, yes, I promise. I hope it does.
非常感谢你让我成为其中的一部分。哦，天哪。我只是，我很高兴我们能让你上节目。我很高兴我们能进行那次记忆之旅。希望这是一种治愈。我希望这是一种治愈。是的，是的，我保证。我希望它会。
Oh, thank you so much, Rich. We love you. Love you, Rich. Thank you. Love you, too. And thanks again for having me. That was so great. Thank you so much, Rich Summer. And now, Jenna. It's time to break down business trip. It is Season 5, Episode 8. Listen to this dream team, written by Brent Forrester and directed by Randall Einhorn. Office ladies, folks, are you ready to go to the International Business Trip? Real, to Kanada. Kanada.
哦，非常感谢你，里奇。我们爱你。爱你，里奇。谢谢。也爱你。再次感谢邀请我。那太棒了。非常感谢里奇·萨默。现在，珍娜。是时候解析“出差”了。这是第五季第八集。听听这个梦之队，由布伦特·福雷斯特编剧，兰德尔·艾因霍恩导演。《办公室》女士们，伙计们，你们准备好去国际出差了吗？真的，去加拿大。加拿大。
Kanada. It's time to go. Get your passport. International traveler. Yes. Let me give you a summary. Please. Michael is ecstatic when David Wallace sends him on an international business trip to Winnipeg, Canada.
加拿大。是时候走了。带上你的护照。国际旅行者。是的。让我给你一个总结。请。迈克尔在戴维·华莱士派他去加拿大温尼伯进行国际商务旅行时欣喜若狂。
Mm-hmm. He brings Oscar and Andy along. While on the trip, Michael romances the concierge and Oscar and Andy Bond. Meanwhile, Jim and the rest of the... of the office, count down the days until Pam's return only to be disappointed when she has to stay in New York for another 12 weeks to retake a course that she failed. Also, Kelly and Ryan get back together. Yes, they do. The deleted scenes on this one are delicious. I'll be sharing some of those. Fast fact number one, we have an awesome guest star alert. Yes, we do. It is Wendy McClendon Covey as
嗯。他带上了奥斯卡和安迪。在旅途中，迈克尔与礼宾员调情，而奥斯卡和安迪建立了友谊。与此同时，吉姆和办公室里的其他人都在倒数帕姆回来的日子，结果却很失望，因为她必须在纽约多待12周，重修一门不及格的课程。另外，凯莉和瑞恩复合了。没错，他们复合了。这一集的删减片段非常精彩。我会分享其中一些。第一个速记事实，我们有一个超棒的客串明星预警。没错，确实有。她是温迪·麦克伦登-考薇，饰演
Concierge Marie. Concierge Marie. How do I love these? She was perfection. You guys might know, Wendy, she is the star of the TV show, The Goldbergs. Yes, she plays Beverly. She was in bridesmaids, so funny.
礼宾员玛丽。礼宾员玛丽。我怎么能这么喜欢她呢？她简直太完美了。你们可能认识温迪，她是电视剧《戈德堡一家》的主演。没错，她饰演贝弗利。她还演过《伴娘》，非常搞笑。
Reno 9-1-1. She is a member of the Groundlink's improv, and she's just an all-around amazing human being. She is, and she was so delightful. We slid into her DMs. We did. And I was like, Wendy, we have some questions. She was like, of course.
《雷诺911》。她是“Groundlings”即兴表演团的成员，而且她是一个全方位都很棒的人。确实如此，她非常讨人喜欢。我们私信了她。我们确实这么做了。我说：“温迪，我们有一些问题。”她说：“当然可以。”
and she sent us fantastic audio clips. Of course we had to ask her how she got her role in the office. I was not expecting this response. I know, me either. Hello, Jenna and Angela, office ladies, gorgeous office ladies. So my audition process, actually I did not have to audition for the office, but it came to me in an interesting way. First of all, I had been in Michigan for not even 24 hours before.
然后她给我们发来了很棒的音频片段。当然，我们必须问她是如何得到《办公室》这个角色的。我没想到会得到这样的回答。我知道，我也没想到。你好，珍娜和安吉拉，办公室女士们，美丽的办公室女士们。关于我的试镜过程，其实我不需要为《办公室》试镜，但这个机会是以一种有趣的方式来到我身边的。首先，我到密歇根州还不到24小时。
I had been fired off of a movie because one of the money guys thought I was too ugly. So I was, my ugly ass was put on a plane back to LAX. And when I got off the plane, there was a message from my agent saying, oh, they want you for the office tomorrow. So I was thrilled. You know, I'd been crying for, I don't know, five hours on a plane. And then I get this news and it's like, yes, I'm so glad I got fired. So when I got to the set the next day, you know, I was a little raw from being told how ugly I was.
我因为一个投资人觉得我太丑而被一部电影解雇了。所以，我这个丑八怪被送上了回洛杉矶国际机场的飞机。当我下飞机时，收到经纪人的一条信息，说：“哦，他们明天想让你去演《办公室》。”所以我很激动。你知道，我在飞机上哭了大概五个小时。然后我得到了这个消息，就像是，太好了，我很高兴我被解雇了。所以第二天我到片场时，你知道，因为被说长得丑，我心里还有点难受。
And I was in my dressing room or my trailer. And one of the PAs came and said, oh, something to the effect of, yeah, you don't look as bad as we thought you were going to. So we don't need to see you right away in the makeup chair. I swear it was something like that. It was like, oh, we're delighted that you don't look like Shrek. type of thing. Oh, Wendy. I mean, we've all had moments like that. That is something about show business where people can get real tacky. Oh, yeah. Well, you know my story where they said I couldn't be on alias because I wasn't hot enough. But then the very next week, I auditioned for a different pilot,
我在化妆间或拖车里。一个制片助理走过来说，大概意思是：“哦，你看起来没我们想象的那么糟糕。所以我们不需要马上让你去化妆椅上。”我发誓大概就是这样。就像是，“哦，我们很高兴你看起来不像史莱克”之类的。哦，温迪。我的意思是，我们都有过那样的时刻。演艺圈就是这样，人们有时会变得非常没品。哦，是的。好吧，你知道我的故事，他们说我不能演《双面女间谍》，因为我不够性感。但就在接下来的一周，我为另一个试播集试镜，
and they said I was too good looking for the role. So I was like, well, I don't know what I am then. I don't know. I can't change my face. I had an agent say to me, you're not Hollywood glamorous, okay? And I said, I know that. I was like, yeah, I know that. Can I be Hollywood dorky, though? You can. Thank you. You did it.
他们说我长得太好看了，不适合那个角色。所以我当时就想，好吧，那我到底是什么样？我不知道。我没法改变我的脸。曾有个经纪人对我说：“你不是好莱坞那种光鲜亮丽的类型，好吗？”我说：“我知道。”我当时想，是的，我知道。但我可以做“好莱坞书呆子”类型吗？你可以的。谢谢。你做到了。
And I did it. Oh, no, gosh. And I've been fired. I was fired from a pilot that I did with Matt LeBlanc. I played his wife. It's on the air still, man with a plan. I was his wife. That was my part.
我做到了。哦，不，天哪。而且我被解雇过。我被一个和马特·勒布朗一起拍的试播集解雇了。我演他的妻子。那部剧还在播，叫《老爸有招》。我演他的妻子。那是我的角色。
Well, I know this story. And you shared it in your book. I did. Mm-hmm. Yeah. I got hired. I shot the pilot. While I was there, the network said they wanted more scenes with me. Oh. I was like, I am nailing it. More scenes means you're doing a good job. Well, I guess after we finished it, they showed it to focus groups. And they didn't like you? No. They liked me, but they said, this is a literal quote. They said, I don't believe Pam would marry Joey. The chemistry doesn't work between these two. That was the feedback they got. They could only see you as Pam and Joey. Yeah. So it wasn't working for them that we got married and had a family. And, you know, the show's called Man with a Plan. It's starring Matt LeBlanc. It's his show. Yeah, I haven't seen it. Okay, well, guess who they can't fire the man with the plan? So out the door I went. I revenge didn't watch.
好吧，我知道这个故事。你在你的书里分享过。我分享过。嗯。是的。我被录用了。我拍了试播集。当我在那里的时候，电视网说他们想增加我的戏份。哦。我当时想，我表现得太棒了。戏份增加意味着你做得很好。好吧，我想在我们拍完之后，他们给焦点小组看了。他们不喜欢你？不。他们喜欢我，但他们说，这是一句原话。他们说：“我不相信帕姆会嫁给乔伊。他们俩之间没有化学反应。”这就是他们得到的反馈。他们只能把你和乔伊看作帕姆和乔伊。是的。所以他们觉得我们结婚并组建家庭行不通。而且，你知道，这部剧叫《老爸有招》。主演是马特·勒布朗。这是他的剧。是的，我没看过。好吧，猜猜他们不能解雇谁？那个“有招的老爸”。所以我被踢出局了。我出于报复没看。
Thank you. I appreciate it. That's your BFF. That's what you're supposed to do. That's right. You fire my BFF. I'm not going to watch your show. But here's the crazy part, lady. The crazy part is that I didn't know I was fired until literally like two days before they were going to announce it at the big press junket in New York. I had packed a suitcase. Tacky!
谢谢。我很感激。那是你的好闺蜜。那是你应该做的。没错。你解雇了我的好闺蜜。我就不看你的剧。但疯狂的部分在这里，女士。疯狂的部分是，直到他们要在纽约举行大型新闻发布会宣布这件事的前两天，我才知道我被解雇了。我已经打包好行李了。真没品！
Because everyone was like, it's going. It's going. It's going to go. It's a sure thing. I had hired hair and makeup to get me ready for all the press. And then I get this call and everyone's on the phone. All my agents, my manager, publicist. Listen, when there's 15 people on the phone, it's either great news are real, real bad. Yeah. And the first thing I said was, is it not getting picked up? And they said, it's worse than that. And I was like, what's worse than that? And I was like, what's worse than that? They said, it's getting picked up, but without you. Oh. And I was like, wow, I guess I'll unpack my suitcase. Dang. Yeah. I almost cut bangs in my hair that day.
因为每个人都说，这剧稳了。稳了。肯定会播的。我甚至雇了发型师和化妆师来为新闻发布会做准备。然后我接到了这个电话，每个人都在线上。我所有的经纪人、经理、公关。听着，当电话里有15个人时，要么是天大的好消息，要么是真的很糟糕。是的。我说的第一句话是：“这剧没被预订吗？”他们说：“比那更糟。”我当时想，还有什么比这更糟的？他们说：“剧被预订了，但没有你。”哦。我当时想，哇，看来我得把行李拆了。该死。是的。那天我差点剪了刘海。
I remember. You stopped me. I didn't want you to cut your hair that day. I said, you know what, let's pick a different day. Let's pick a different day to change your whole look. You did send me a picture, though, of you jumping in the air flipping off the world. I did. I said, that's better. Go jump around. Flip off anyone you want in the air. Do not cut your hair today. You were a good friend of me that day. And I will never watch that show. Sorry, Matt LeBlanc. I actually love you. And I love Joey. But I'm sorry. I liked Matt LeBlanc too. He was very nice.
我记得。你阻止了我。我不想让你那天剪头发。我说，你知道吗，换个日子吧。换个日子来改变你的整体造型。不过你确实给我发了一张照片，你跳在空中，向全世界竖中指。我发了。我说，那样更好。去跳吧。在空中向任何你想竖中指的人竖中指。今天别剪头发。那天你真是我的好朋友。我永远不会看那部剧。抱歉，马特·勒布朗。其实我爱你。我也爱乔伊。但我很抱歉。我也喜欢马特·勒布朗。他很友善。
Anyway. All right. Well, Wendy, I am sorry you got fired because you are a talent and a force and I love you. Yes. And thank you for texting me, emailing me. Let's see. Fast fact number two, Michael goes on his business trip to Winnipeg in this episode. And we got a lot of questions from people, why Winnipeg? How did they choose this location? Well, like I said before, this episode was written by Brent Forrester and he did an interview. You mean to the CBC, Jenna? That's the one. And did you find it as well? Did we both Google Real Good this episode? We Googled Real Good. CBC is the Canadian broadcast company. Yes. I'm like so proud that I know what CBC stands for. Well, they asked him, why Winnipeg? They did. Some good journalism. He explained that they knew they wanted this to be an international business trip, that they tossed around the idea of Montreal or Vancouver, but in the end, they chose Winnipeg because it seemed to strike the right balance between, quote, exotic and obscure.
总之。好吧，温迪，我很抱歉你被解雇了，因为你很有才华，很有力量，我爱你。是的。谢谢你给我发短信、发邮件。让我们看看。第二个速记事实，迈克尔在这一集中去温尼伯出差。我们收到了很多人的提问，为什么是温尼伯？他们是怎么选择这个地点的？嗯，就像我之前说的，这一集是由布伦特·福雷斯特写的，他接受了一次采访。你是说接受加拿大广播公司（CBC）的采访吗，珍娜？就是那个。你也找到了吗？我们俩是不是都为这一集做了很好的谷歌搜索？我们谷歌得很好。CBC是加拿大广播公司。是的。我为自己知道CBC代表什么感到自豪。好吧，他们问他，为什么是温尼伯？他们问了。很好的新闻报道。他解释说，他们知道他们想让这成为一次国际商务旅行，他们考虑过蒙特利尔或温哥华，但最终，他们选择了温尼伯，因为它似乎在“异国情调”和“默默无闻”之间取得了恰到好处的平衡。
Yes. And you know what else I loved in this interview? Brent shared that Phil Shea, our prop master, reached out to the Winnipeg Tourism Promotion Agency, and they sent along all kinds of stuff like airport baggage tags, shopping bags from the Bay, old Dutch potato chips, which was founded in Winnipeg in 1954. And you're going to see those on the bar. I became obsessed. Maybe because I watched this episode while I was hungry, I will have some old Dutch potato chip tracking and also flavors to share with you.
是的。而且你知道我在这篇采访中还喜欢什么吗？布伦特分享说，我们的道具师菲尔·谢联系了温尼伯旅游推广局，他们寄来了各种各样的东西，比如机场行李牌、海湾百货的购物袋、老荷兰薯片，这是1954年在温尼伯创立的。你们会在酒吧里看到这些。我变得着迷了。也许是因为我饿着肚子看这一集，我会分享一些关于老荷兰薯片的追踪信息，还有口味。
there for it. And also they sent some Fort Gary Brewing Company paraphernalia and all kinds of other stuff. Yes, because we did not go to Winnipeg. We shop this whole episode in Los Angeles. So we had to just make it look as canada as possible. Faky Canada. Yes. Fast fact number three, even though we didn't go to Winnipeg, I have some fun facts about Winnipeg. And these were all sent in by fans. Oh, I love it. Office Ladies Listeners, who are from Winnipeg, wanted us to know these things. Okay. So first from Leah Patterson, Winnie the Pooh was named after the city of Winnipeg. Get out. I didn't know that. I didn't know that. Yeah. A lot of people know that the writer of Winnie the Pooh had a son named Christopher Robin, and his son Christopher Robin had a little stuffed bear named
在那儿。他们还寄来了一些堡垒加里酿酒公司的周边产品和各种其他东西。是的，因为我们没有去温尼伯。我们在洛杉矶拍摄了整集。所以我们必须让它看起来尽可能像加拿大。伪加拿大。是的。第三个速记事实，尽管我们没去温尼伯，但我有一些关于温尼伯的有趣事实。这些都是粉丝寄来的。哦，我喜欢。来自温尼伯的《办公室女士》听众想让我们知道这些事情。好的。首先来自莉亚·帕特森，小熊维尼的名字是以温尼伯市命名的。别开玩笑了。我不知道。我不知道。是的。很多人知道小熊维尼的作者有一个儿子叫克里斯托弗·罗宾，他的儿子克里斯托弗·罗宾有一个小毛绒熊叫
Winnie. And that's where he got the idea for the characters. But do you know why his son named his bear Winnie? I do. Why? I don't know. Oh. I'm just messing. with you. I have no idea. There's probably a small number of people that know this, right? Well, I don't know. Leah Patterson knows. Okay, Leah, why? Because in 1915, a black bear was rescued by a cavalry veterinarian who named the bear Winnie after his hometown of Winnipeg. And then he gave the bear to the London Zoo. And that's where the real Christopher Robin saw the bear, loved the bear, and then named his little stuffed bear after Winnie. Oh. So it's a little roundabout. It's hard to explain. I'm sorry if I took you on a real circle there, but the bottom line is, yes, Winnie the Pooh is named after the city of Winnipeg. Well, Leah, I love knowing that. What else you got? More from Leah. More from Leah. Yes. Okay. Winnipeg has been the slurpy capital of the world for almost 20 years. Wait, like slurpy like you get at 7-Eleven? That's right. They literally sell the most slurpees every year. Come on. Yep. My kids love a slurpy. I looked it up. It's true. Got to go to Winnipeg. More from Leah. Okay. Leah, you are a treasure trove of information about Winnipeg. Where do you work? Do you work at the tourism? Promotion Agency? You should. Winnipeg was also the first city in North America to use 911.
维尼。这就是他创作角色的灵感来源。但你知道他儿子为什么把他的熊叫维尼吗？我知道。为什么？我不知道。哦。我只是在逗你。我真的不知道。可能只有少数人知道这个，对吧？好吧，我不知道。莉亚·帕特森知道。好的，莉亚，为什么？因为在1915年，一只黑熊被一名骑兵兽医救下，他以自己的家乡温尼伯（Winnipeg）为这只熊取名为维尼（Winnie）。然后他把这只熊送到了伦敦动物园。真正的克里斯托弗·罗宾就是在那里看到了这只熊，非常喜欢它，然后以维尼的名字命名了他的小毛绒熊。哦。所以这是一个有点绕的过程。很难解释。很抱歉我带你绕了个大圈，但底线是，是的，小熊维尼确实是以温尼伯市命名的。好吧，莉亚，我很高兴知道这一点。你还有什么？更多来自莉亚的消息。更多来自莉亚。是的。好的。温尼伯近20年来一直是世界思乐冰之都。等等，就像你在7-11买的那种思乐冰？没错。他们每年卖出的思乐冰确实是最多的。得了吧。是的。我的孩子们喜欢思乐冰。我查过了。是真的。一定要去温尼伯。更多来自莉亚。好的。莉亚，你真是温尼伯信息的宝库。你在哪里工作？你在旅游推广局工作吗？你应该去那里。温尼伯也是北美第一个使用911的城市。
They invented 911? I don't know. They were the first city to use it. It happened in 1959. Wow. This one from Taylor Naccarado, Winnipeg can get to close to negative 30 degrees Celsius in the winter, and we have actually broken a record for being colder than the planet Mars in 2019. Oh, this is a tough sell for Winnipeg. On New Year's Eve, the Mars Curiosity rover posted a temperature of negative 29 degrees Celsius. Now, that's actually very warm for Mars. Yeah. If you are interested, the average temperature on Mars is about negative 55 degrees Celsius,
他们发明了911？我不知道。他们是第一个使用它的城市。这发生在1959年。哇。这条来自泰勒·纳卡拉多，温尼伯冬天的气温可以接近零下30摄氏度，而且我们在2019年甚至打破了比火星还冷的记录。哦，这对温尼伯来说是个很难推销的点。在新年前夜，火星好奇号探测器记录的温度是零下29摄氏度。现在，这对火星来说其实非常温暖。是的。如果你感兴趣的话，火星的平均温度大约是零下55摄氏度，
but it can get as cold as negative 150 degrees Celsius at the poles. But on this warm day on Mars, it was negative 29, and on that same day in Winnipeg, it was colder than Mars by a few degrees. Dang. Very cold. Taylor N would like you to know that Winnipeg is a very very cold. diverse multicultural city, and they host something called Folklorama. It's one of the largest and longest running multicultural festivals in the world. It has over 40 pavilions where they embrace cultures of different countries, and you can watch singing and dancing and sample different foods from that country. I would go to that. That sounds so fun. I would love that. Well, listen, I think we should
但在极地可以冷到零下150摄氏度。但在火星那个温暖的日子里，温度是零下29度，而同一天在温尼伯，气温比火星还要低几度。该死。非常冷。泰勒·N想让你知道，温尼伯是一个非常非常寒冷、多元文化的城市，他们举办一种叫“Folklorama”的活动。它是世界上规模最大、历史最悠久的多元文化节日之一。它有超过40个展馆，拥抱不同国家的文化，你可以观看歌舞，品尝来自那个国家的各种食物。我会去参加那个。听起来很有趣。我会很喜欢的。好吧，听着，我觉得我们应该
take a break. I think that's a good idea. Well, get an iced tea. We're going to come back, And I'm excited to break down business trip. Let's do it. All right, you guys, we are back. We are in the conference room. Michael is teaching the group about various cultures and how to travel to those cultures. International behaviors. Yes.
休息一下。我觉得这是个好主意。去喝杯冰茶吧。我们要回来了，我很兴奋能解析这一集《出差》。开始吧。好了，伙计们，我们回来了。我们在会议室。迈克尔正在教大家关于各种文化以及如何去那些文化中旅行。国际行为。是的。
Jenna, background catch at eight seconds. You can see Kate staring at me, but I can tell it's Kate and not Meredith. She's kind of looking at me like, uh-huh. And then very quickly in the corner, you can see me futzing with my microphone. Oh, was she trying to tell you we could see your microphone? I think something happened. Either my microphone dropped and I was trying to fix it. And Kate was trying to be like, camera's coming. Something. There's a moment here. But you can see me. It's very quick. I'm like fudcing with my collar doing something.
珍娜，八秒处的背景捕捉。你可以看到凯特盯着我，但我能看出那是凯特而不是梅雷迪斯。她看着我的样子就像是，“嗯哼”。然后很快在角落里，你可以看到我在摆弄我的麦克风。哦，她是想告诉你我们能看到你的麦克风吗？我想发生了什么事。要么是我的麦克风掉了，我在试图修好它。凯特想提醒我“摄像机来了”。之类的。这里有个瞬间。但你可以看到我。非常快。我在摆弄我的领子，做些什么。
Yeah. Anyway, it tickled me. It tickled me. Well, the reason for this conference room scene is so that Michael can explain to us that he is being, sent to Wu an international client. Right. This whole meeting could have been an email. Yeah. Yeah. The other thing that's happening is we learn that Pam is coming home in 6.5 days. Yes. And the office is very excited for Jim. Everyone at Dundermifflin, Kevin smacks his butt, Creed gives him a kind of a creepy shoulder rub. Phyllis smiles and says one more week. When Phyllis smiles and says one more week, please look at her desk. It is covered. with tissues. I don't know what was happening. Oh, she must have had a cold. Something. I just love the fact that we didn't bother to tidy the desk. No, it's real life. It's real life mixed with fake life.
是的。总之，这逗乐了我。它逗乐了我。好吧，这个会议室场景的原因是迈克尔想向我们解释他被派去见一个国际客户。没错。这次会议完全可以通过电子邮件解决。是的。另一件事是，我们得知帕姆还有6.5天就要回家了。是的。办公室为吉姆感到非常兴奋。邓德·米夫林的所有人，凯文拍了他的屁股，克里德给了他一个有点令人毛骨悚然的肩膀按摩。菲利斯笑着说“还有一周”。当菲利斯笑着说“还有一周”时，请看她的桌子。上面全是纸巾。我不知道发生了什么。哦，她一定感冒了。之类的。我只是喜欢我们没有费心去整理桌子这一点。不，这是真实生活。这是真实生活与虚假生活的混合。
Stanley gives Jim a look and goes, eh, eh. And in a deleted scene, Jenna, Kelly helps Jim make a sign saying, welcome back. And she's really annoyed because he needs to use more glitter. Oh, yeah. We had a fan question from Chris S about this scene with Jim. Chris said, I would like to know the specific stage direction Creed was given when he massages Jim's shoulders as he comforts him. He really liked this moment. I looked it up in the script. What did it say? In the script, it actually said this, quote,
斯坦利看了吉姆一眼，说：“呃，呃。”在一段删减片段中，珍娜，凯莉帮吉姆做了一个写着“欢迎回来”的牌子。她真的很恼火，因为他需要用更多的亮粉。哦，是的。我们有一个来自克里斯·S的粉丝提问，关于吉姆的这个场景。克里斯说：“我想知道克里德在安慰吉姆并按摩他肩膀时，得到了什么具体的舞台指导。他真的很喜欢这个时刻。”我在剧本里查了一下。上面写了什么？在剧本里，它实际上是这样写的，引用：
Creed passes Jim, he punches Jim's shoulder, and then musses Jim's hair. hair. So this massage, they must have found it on the day because in the script he was supposed to give him a punch and a hair must. Well, I think it's funnier because Kevin's already smacked his butt. Yeah. So it's like a smack and a punch. I think this is way funnier. Also, John Krasinski's reactions to everyone, that's what makes it. Yeah. His face when Creed comes up behind him is so good. So now Michael is on the phone with David Wallace. He's got his passport. ready. He's got his per diem. Fifty bucks. He's going to buy a sweater. He is. He'll use other money for food. Yeah. And he has a plane ticket. He does. On Butute Airlines? B-U-T-T-E. But airlines? Well, I think it's probably Butte. I looked it up. I did too. I found nothing.
“克里德经过吉姆，他打了吉姆的肩膀，然后弄乱了吉姆的头发。”所以这个按摩，他们一定是当天临时想到的，因为在剧本里他应该打他一下并弄乱他的头发。好吧，我觉得这更有趣，因为凯文已经拍了他的屁股。是的。所以这就像是一个拍打和一个拳击。我觉得这有趣多了。而且，约翰·卡拉辛斯基对每个人的反应，那才是精髓。是的。当克里德走到他身后时，他的表情太棒了。所以现在迈克尔正在和戴维·华莱士通电话。他准备好了护照。他拿到了每日津贴。五十块钱。他要买一件毛衣。他会的。他会用剩下的钱买食物。是的。他有一张机票。他确实有。在“Butte”航空公司？B-U-T-T-E。But航空公司？好吧，我想大概是Butte。我查过了。我也查了。我什么也没找到。
I found zilch. Not an airline. Not real. Faky airline. I want to know more, though. Why they settled on Butte? I think it was but. Oh, come on, really? I don't know. Why would you call it Butte Airline? I don't know. We don't know. We're sorry. Sorry, guys, it could be Butte or but, but it's a faky airline. Oh, here's something. Michael is going to bring two extra giant suitcases for souvenirs. Empty. Empty. They're empty. Mm-hmm. Do you do that? Do you bring an extra empty bag? Do you leave room? As you're packing, do you consider? I can't pack this totally full because I know I'm going to purchase something. Or are you the person who gets to your vacation and it's time to go home and then you have to go buy like an extra canvas bag to get all your stuff home?
我一无所获。不是一家航空公司。不是真的。伪航空公司。不过我想知道更多。为什么他们决定叫Butte航空公司？我想大概是But。哦，得了吧，真的吗？我不知道。你为什么会叫它Butte航空公司？我不知道。我们不知道。很抱歉。抱歉，伙计们，可能是Butte或But，但这是一个伪航空公司。哦，这里有个东西。迈克尔要带两个巨大的额外行李箱装纪念品。空的。空的。它们是空的。嗯。你会那样做吗？你会带一个额外的空包吗？你会留出空间吗？当你打包时，你会考虑吗？我不能把这个装得太满，因为我知道我要买点东西。或者你是那种到了度假地，准备回家时，才不得不去买一个额外的帆布包把所有东西带回家的人？
Ding, ding, ding, ding. Yeah. That's me. Yeah. That's why I have a plethora of real rando bags. Yeah. Because usually you're in a tight spot. Yep.
叮，叮，叮，叮。是的。那就是我。是的。这就是为什么我有一大堆乱七八糟的包。是的。因为通常你处于紧迫的境地。是的。
You don't have a lot of options. Yeah. I once had a travel bag that looked like a zebra. Mm-hmm. Because I had to buy it at the airport to fit my souvenirs because my suitcase was starting to like, like, yeah, start to look like it was going to tear. And for a long time, we had the zebra suitcase. Yeah. Yeah.
你没有太多选择。是的。我曾经有一个看起来像斑马的旅行包。嗯。因为我不得不在机场买它来装我的纪念品，因为我的行李箱开始看起来要裂开了。很长一段时间里，我们都有那个斑马行李箱。是的。是的。
Guess which one I am. You're the first one. I leave the room. You leave the room. I anticipate my souvenir purchases. You're not walking through an airport with a zebra bag? No rando bags for me. I'm a rando bag.
猜猜我是哪一种。你是第一种。我留出了空间。你留出了空间。我预料到了我的纪念品购买。你不会带着斑马包穿过机场吧？我没有乱七八糟的包。我是乱七八糟包的拥有者。
Listen, rando bag happened to me once, never again. Mm. You know what I'm saying? Yeah. Like, I have a random suitcase from Scotland. I still love it. It looks like a travel trunk from like Joe versus the volcano. This is the problem. Sometimes you get a real find when you're in a bind. I know. Ooh, I rhymed it. You did. I'm still rhyming. You are. Stop it. If you can pause on rhyming, I want to tell you one other thing that's happening in this scene. I can't. Can you? I can try. I was going to try to rhyme, but I couldn't think of anything. I know. I know. I was trying to set you up. Anyway, while this whole suitcase business is happening, lady in the background, I am telling you, Pam's puffer coat is hanging on the coat rack. It's not Pam's coat. Come on.
听着，乱七八糟包的情况发生在我身上一次，再也不会了。嗯。你知道我在说什么吗？是的。就像，我有一个来自苏格兰的随机行李箱。我仍然很喜欢它。它看起来像《乔对决火山》里的旅行箱。这就是问题所在。有时你在困境中会得到一个真正的发现。我知道。哦，我押韵了。你确实押韵了。我还在押韵。你还在押韵。停下。如果你能暂停押韵，我想告诉你这个场景中发生的另一件事。我不能。你能吗？我可以试着。我本来想试着押韵，但我什么也想不出来。我知道。我知道。我本来想给你搭个台子。总之，当这整个行李箱的事情发生时，背景里的女士，我告诉你，帕姆的羽绒服挂在衣架上。那不是帕姆的衣服。得了吧。
It's not her coat. How do you know? Because somebody wrote in about it and I zoomed in on it. It's not my coat. It sure looks like your coat. It's not mine. Who wrote in? It was me.
那不是她的衣服。你怎么知道？因为有人写信问过这件事，我放大了看。那不是我的衣服。看起来确实像你的衣服。那不是我的。谁写的信？是我。
Angela Kaye wrote in several times. More male than anyone. I zoomed in too. And it sure. looks like that puffer coat you used to wear. I know it looks like it, but it's not my puffer coat. I think it might be Meredith's had a similar puffer coat. Okay. Well, there you go. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Guess who else gets to come on this trip? Besides the money belt and the two empty suitcases? Yeah. Andy is going to join him as his translator. He will be translating all of the French that they don't speak in Winnipeg.
安吉拉·凯写了好几次。比任何人都多。我也放大了看。它看起来确实像你以前穿的那件羽绒服。我知道它看起来像，但那不是我的羽绒服。我想那可能是梅雷迪斯的，她有一件类似的羽绒服。好吧。好吧，就是这样。嗯。猜猜还有谁要参加这次旅行？除了腰包和两个空行李箱？是的。安迪要作为他的翻译加入。他将翻译他们在温尼伯不说的那种法语。
Well, we did learn in a deleted scene in dinner party. Angela said that Andy learned French during his semester in France. So this is kind of a callback. Kind of a callback. Then Andy speaks some not great French. Oh, a lot of not great French. Mixed in with some Spanish. Oscar is also going on the trip.
好吧，我们在《晚宴》的一段删减片段中确实了解到，安吉拉说安迪在法国留学期间学过法语。所以这算是一种呼应。算是一种呼应。然后安迪说了一些不太好的法语。哦，很多不太好的法语。混杂着一些西班牙语。奥斯卡也要去旅行。
I don't really know Oscar's role. Why would he be going? Something to do with crunching numbers, maybe? Maybe. I'm so glad that Oscar went because, Jenna, there are so many Fantastic deleted Oscar scenes and Oscar andy scenes if you have the DVDs. And you guys, Oscar does that thing in these deleted scenes. Like what he did with Holly in employee transfer. I have a new term for Oscar. He's the office fun stopper. Oh. You might think it's Angela Barton, but kind of like
我真的不知道奥斯卡的角色是什么。他为什么要跟着去？可能和计算数字有关？可能。我很高兴奥斯卡去了，因为，珍娜，如果你有DVD的话，有太多精彩的奥斯卡删减片段，还有奥斯卡和安迪的片段。伙计们，奥斯卡在这些删减片段里做了那件事。就像他在《员工调动》里对霍莉做的那样。我对奥斯卡有一个新称呼。他是“办公室乐趣终结者”。哦。你可能以为是安吉拉·马丁，但有点像
Debbie Downer on S&L. Yeah. Oscar is always going to have that sidebar comment that's a little too honest for the moment. Takes the wind out of your sales. Takes the wind out of your sales. All right. So now they're on the plane. Mm-hmm. Michael is up in business class. He's got a mimosa. He has a moist hand towel that's still wet. Mm-hmm.
《周六夜现场》里的黛比·唐纳。是的。奥斯卡总是会发表那种对当下来说太诚实的侧面评论。让你的兴致全无。让你的兴致全无。好吧。所以现在他们在飞机上。嗯。迈克尔在商务舱。他有一杯含羞草鸡尾酒。他有一条还是湿的湿手巾。嗯。
We got a lot of fan questions from Kyle T. Sarah M., Steph Hernandez, and Madison C. Did you guys film on an actual airplane? If so, which airport and airline were used for this episode? Well, we have some information for you. Yes, we do. Thanks to Randy Cordray, who was our line produced. who took over for Kent Zabornak, he gave us the lowdown. The interior airplane scenes were filmed at a place called Air Hollywood in Pekoyma, California.
我们收到了来自凯尔·T、莎拉·M、斯蒂芬·埃尔南德斯和麦迪逊·C的很多粉丝提问。你们是在真正的飞机上拍摄的吗？如果是的话，这一集用了哪个机场和航空公司？好吧，我们有一些信息给你们。是的，确实有。多亏了我们的制片主任兰迪·科德雷，他接替了肯特·扎博纳克，他给了我们内幕消息。飞机内部场景是在加利福尼亚州帕科伊马一个叫“好莱坞航空”的地方拍摄的。
And at the time, this company was, I guess, like the go-to location for all things airline-related. Yeah, it was like a set, but for airplanes. Yeah. So if you needed a plane to film, they were ready for you. Yeah. He said they had all these soundstages. they had various aircraft, various airport-related props. They even had like interior airport kind of stuff.
当时，这家公司大概是所有与航空公司相关事物的首选地点。是的，它就像一个片场，但专门用于飞机。是的。所以如果你需要一架飞机来拍摄，他们随时准备着。是的。他说他们有所有这些摄影棚。他们有各种飞机、各种与机场相关的道具。他们甚至有像机场内部那样的东西。
So we used the interior of a jet for Michael in business class and Andy and Oscar and Coach. He explained that these airplanes can be split down the middle. Yeah. Well, Michael is going to introduce Oscar and Andy, you know, before they go back to coach, to Beth, who he says is his personal valet. slash flight attendant, and she's going to be helping him this morning. I love Beth. I love Beth.
所以我们用了喷气式飞机的内部给迈克尔在商务舱，安迪和奥斯卡在经济舱。他解释说这些飞机可以从中间分开。是的。好吧，迈克尔要在他们回经济舱之前，向贝丝介绍奥斯卡和安迪，他说贝丝是他的私人管家兼空乘，她今天早上会帮助他。我喜欢贝丝。我喜欢贝丝。
When I watched it, it reminded me of the woman who played the transcriber in the deposition. Just no nonsense. Just did we hire an actual flight attendant to play this role? She's so, like, over my goal and the camera. We did not. This is an actress. Her name is Deb Height. She has been on The Good Place.
当我观看时，它让我想起了在《证词》中扮演速记员的那个女人。就是那种不废话的风格。我们雇了一个真正的空乘来扮演这个角色吗？她看起来太像我的目标了，还有摄像机。我们没有。这是一位女演员。她的名字叫黛布·海特。她演过《善地》。
Barry, Curb Your Enthusiasm, Veep, Baskets, Arrested Development, Parks and Recreation. She's a writer. She has written plays. She has written award-winning pilots, award-winning short films, and she wrote a comedy book about the rivalry between the Alabama-Auburn College football teams called When Mommy Loves Bama and Daddy Loves Auburn. You can find it on Amazon. It's really cute. We were so lucky. We say this every week. Oh my gosh. We say it every week. But seriously, every single person hired on the show always crushed it and was amazing. My favorite moment is when she slams Michael's Lake with the cart. I know. It's Steve's reaction though. Steve's reaction. That was like amazing. It's too good. While Michael's getting his foot run over with the beverage card, Andy is really trying to bond with Oscar back in coat. This is a deleted scene. It is amazing. It's Oscar the Fun Stopper, guys.
《巴瑞》、《抑制热情》、《副总统》、《篮子》、《发展受阻》、《公园与游憩》。她是一位作家。她写过剧本。她写过获奖的试播集、获奖的短片，她还写过一本关于阿拉巴马大学和奥本大学橄榄球队之间竞争的喜剧书，叫《当妈妈爱阿拉巴马，爸爸爱奥本》。你可以在亚马逊上找到它。真的很可爱。我们太幸运了。我们每周都这么说。哦，天哪。我们每周都这么说。但说真的，剧组雇的每一个人总是表现出色，令人惊叹。我最喜欢的时刻是她用推车撞了迈克尔的腿。我知道。那是史蒂夫的反应。史蒂夫的反应。那真是太棒了。太好了。当迈克尔的脚被饮料车碾过时，安迪真的在经济舱试图和奥斯卡建立联系。这是一个删减片段。太棒了。这是奥斯卡“乐趣终结者”，伙计们。
Honey roasted peanuts. Am I right? I don't understand the question. Yes, you're holding a bag of peanuts. I'll save that for later. That just made me laugh so hard because Andy's like trying to bond. He's like, Honey Roasted Peanuts. But what are you supposed to say to that? I know, but... I'm with Oscar. I know, but this is my point. Yes. You're holding peanuts.
蜂蜜烤花生。我说得对吗？我不明白这个问题。是的，你手里拿着一袋花生。我留着以后吃。这让我笑得太厉害了，因为安迪试图建立联系。他说：“蜂蜜烤花生。”但你对此能说什么呢？我知道，但是……我站在奥斯卡这边。我知道，但这就是我的观点。是的。你手里拿着花生。
I know, but Oscar cannot edit. Like, I think other people would be like, I know, they're really good, you know, or something. But Oscar's just like, I don't understand what you're saying to me. I have to say, I actually really love a honey roasted peanut on an airplane. So I would probably respond. I might actually be Andy in this scenario. I just thought that was really good Oscar, the fun stopper. But, you know, if Oscar's not going to be fun, at least Andy has his DVD player and he's going to watch Harry and the Hendersons.
我知道，但奥斯卡无法编辑。就像，我觉得其他人会说：“我知道，它们很好吃，你知道吗？”或者之类的。但奥斯卡只是说：“我不明白你在对我说什么。”我必须说，我其实真的很喜欢飞机上的蜂蜜烤花生。所以我可能会回应。在这种情况下，我可能就是安迪。我只是觉得那是很好的奥斯卡，“乐趣终结者”。但是，你知道，如果奥斯卡不打算有趣，至少安迪有他的DVD播放机，他要看《哈利与亨德森一家》。
Yeah. I think we should talk about what's happening over at Dunder Mifflin. Oh, yeah. Pam's coming back, which means Ryan is going to have to move into Kelly's nook. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. And he's looking for a place he might be able to do his push-ups. He needs space to do push-ups. He does. It's kind of tight and cramped over there, but he's going to try. He's going to find a way. We had a fan question. How many push-ups did BJ have to do in this episode? He must have been so sore. I want to hear this because I want to hear this because I'm I, as Jenna knows, I texted BJ last night and I said, by the way, I just watched you do a one-arm push-up and then business trip. Dang, BJ. Well, I texted with BJ about his push-ups as well. And he said he doesn't remember how many takes they did, but he said that Mindy definitely wrote this scene. He said, there was a period of time when all the writers were doing push-up contests. And that might have inspired it. But also at the same time, he was in training because he was prepping to do the Tarantino movie in Glorious Bastards.
是的。我觉得我们应该谈谈邓德·米夫林那边发生了什么。哦，是的。帕姆要回来了，这意味着瑞恩将不得不搬进凯莉的角落。嗯。嗯。他正在寻找一个可以做俯卧撑的地方。他需要空间做俯卧撑。他确实需要。那边有点挤，但他会尝试的。他会找到办法的。我们有一个粉丝提问。BJ在这一集中必须做多少个俯卧撑？他一定很酸痛。我想听听这个，因为我想听听这个，因为我，正如珍娜所知，我昨晚给BJ发了短信，我说：“顺便说一句，我刚看你在《出差》里做了一个单手俯卧撑。该死，BJ。”好吧，我也和BJ发短信聊了他的俯卧撑。他说他不记得他们拍了多少次，但他说是敏迪绝对写了这个场景。他说，有一段时间所有的编剧都在进行俯卧撑比赛。这可能启发了它。但同时，他也在训练，因为他准备去拍昆汀的电影《无耻混蛋》。
Oh, yeah. He was getting in really good shape for that because he was going to be a soldier. Yeah. So he was doing push-ups in the writer's room all the time. He had to literally find room to do push-ups at work. So Mindy might have been going off of that as well. But also, maybe she just wanted to make BJ have to do a bunch of push-ups in a scene. And then a one-arm push-up.
哦，是的。他为那个角色练出了很好的身材，因为他要演一名士兵。是的。所以他一直在编剧室里做俯卧撑。他必须在工作中真正找到做俯卧撑的空间。所以敏迪可能也是受此启发。但也许，她只是想让BJ在场景中做一堆俯卧撑。然后是一个单手俯卧撑。
Yeah. See, that's a moment where if I'm BJ, I'm like, I'm so glad I got that on camera. That I did it at least once. Yeah. I'll always have that. Well, listen, Kelly is claiming she's not impressed. Ryan has hurt her too much. It is not going to happen.
是的。看，如果我是BJ，我会想，我很高兴我把它拍下来了。我至少做了一次。是的。我永远会有那个时刻。好吧，听着，凯莉声称她没被打动。瑞恩伤她太深了。这不会发生的。
No, she is in a healthy relationship with Daryl. That door is closed. Cut to. Major makeout. That's kissy sounds. Yeah. I could tell. Oh, you could.
不，她和达里尔处于一段健康的关系中。那扇门关上了。切到。激烈的亲吻。那是亲吻的声音。是的。我能听出来。哦，你能。
Okay. M-w-w-w-w-w-w-w. You did it. Back in Winnipeg, the guys are arriving at the hotel. It's so beautiful, Michael says he could live there. We had a fan catch from Tori, Mary, and Katie, who said, Michael left Dunder Mifflin with multiple suitcases, but he shows up at the hotel with only his carry-on.
好的。M-w-w-w-w-w-w-w。你做到了。回到温尼伯，伙计们到达了酒店。太美了，迈克尔说他可以住在这里。我们收到了来自托里、玛丽和凯蒂的粉丝捕捉，他们说：“迈克尔带着多个行李箱离开了邓德·米夫林，但他只带着随身行李出现在酒店。”
What happened to his souvenir suitcases? Well, guys, I'll tell you. They're there. You have to look deep in the background. At six minutes, 37 seconds, you can. see the bellman loading the suitcases onto a trolley. Oh. As Michael goes up, snap.
他的纪念品行李箱怎么了？好吧，伙计们，我告诉你们。它们在那儿。你必须往背景深处看。在6分37秒，你可以看到行李员把行李箱装上手推车。哦。当迈克尔走上，啪。
The escalator. So don't worry. He has them and he's going to get those souvenirs. Yeah. They're going to put them in his room. Jenna, this hotel has something sort of magical about it, fantastical. It's called a concierge. Oh, yeah. Mm-hmm.
自动扶梯。所以别担心。他有它们，他会得到那些纪念品的。是的。他们会把它们放进他的房间。珍娜，这家酒店有一种神奇的东西，梦幻般的。它叫礼宾部。哦，是的。嗯。
I don't know if you've ever heard of it. Oh, yeah. You know, they help you with the fine art of fanciness and pleasure. Mm-hmm. These guys are going to try it out. they're going to go over and they're going to ask her a bunch of questions. And guess what? What? Almost nothing she says is true. But I just love how completely blown away Michael is that she knows restaurants and their street address and the best way to get there. This is mind-blowing to him.
我不知道你有没有听说过。哦，是的。你知道，他们帮你处理那种精致和愉悦的艺术。嗯。这些人要试一试。他们要走过去，问她一堆问题。你猜怎么着？什么？她说的几乎没有一句是真的。但我只是喜欢迈克尔对她知道餐馆、街道地址以及到达那里的最佳路线感到完全震惊的样子。这对他来说太震撼了。
This is such a real concierge interaction when she pulls out the map. The map and circles it and then tells them two different routes and two different means of transportation. Perfection. Perfection. But we did have a lot of fans from Winnipeg who wrote in. Again, Kimberly Kay said, did the writers know that everything Concierge Marie said about Winnipeg is inaccurate? Was this on purpose? Oh. Natalie V. said the number 17 bus is real, but it runs a lot later than 9 p.m. It goes till almost 1 a.m.
当她拿出地图时，这真是太真实的礼宾互动了。地图，圈出它，然后告诉他们两条不同的路线和两种不同的交通方式。完美。完美。但我们确实收到了很多来自温尼伯的粉丝来信。再次，金伯利·凯说：“编剧们知道礼宾员玛丽关于温尼伯所说的一切都是不准确的吗？这是故意的吗？”哦。娜塔莉·V说：“17路公交车是真的，但它运行的时间比晚上9点晚得多。它一直运行到凌晨1点左右。”
It wouldn't be the only bus to the Exchange District, which does not exist. I think they meant the financial district. And then Leah P. said, we also don't have an astro cleaners. Or the restaurants or the bar. No, the huntsman is not a real bar. And neither is the sushi place. Yes. Well, Angela, we have another story happening in this episode.
它不会是去交易所区的唯一公交车，那个区根本不存在。我想他们指的是金融区。然后莉亚·P说：“我们也没有Astro清洁公司。或者那些餐馆或酒吧。不，Huntsman不是一家真正的酒吧。那家寿司店也不是。”是的。好吧，安吉拉，我们在这一集中还有另一个故事。
It's Pam, right? It's a big story. Well, she's supposed to be coming home from art school, but we're going to have a phone call between her and Jim, and they're going to find out. some news. She's failing her flash class. Yeah. She's going to have to take it again. If she wants to pass art school she does, that means she has to stay another 12 weeks. Is this art school like just digital art? Does she get to do any of the art that she's actually really good at? I don't know. It seems like this was mostly a graphic design program. Yeah. Well, I had to cry in this scene. It was in the script that I'm holding back tears. And there's a lot that is.
是帕姆，对吧？这是一个大故事。好吧，她应该从艺术学校回家了，但我们要进行一个她和吉姆之间的电话，他们会发现一些新闻。她不及格她的Flash课程。是的。她将不得不重修它。如果她想通过艺术学校，她就得重修，这意味着她必须再待12周。这所艺术学校只是数字艺术吗？她能做任何她真正擅长的艺术吗？我不知道。看起来这主要是平面设计课程。是的。好吧，我必须在这个场景中哭。剧本里写着我忍住泪水。而且有很多事情是
coming down on Pam right now. She's dealing with the fact that she didn't complete this course and the idea of being away from Jim even longer. But I had something else that I was playing. We'll get to it. Okay. Well, I thought it was a very moving scene. And it just reminds me of those moments, you guys, when life happens, even though everything around you just keeps moving on. So Pam is sitting down. It's like a busy stairwell. People are going up and down. And she's having a life moment. Yeah. I thought that was very relatable. Well, Jenna, back in Winnipeg, the fellows are going to arrive at Huntsman Bar. Yes. We shot these scenes at the seven grand bar and grill in Los Angeles. Did you notice at nine minutes, 20 seconds, what the chalkboard says at the Huntsman? No. This is what
帕姆现在正面临着。她正在处理她没有完成这门课程的事实，以及不得不离开吉姆更长时间的想法。但我还在演别的东西。我们稍后再说。好的。好吧，我觉得这是一个非常感人的场景。它让我想起了那些时刻，伙计们，当生活发生时，即使你周围的一切都在继续前进。所以帕姆坐了下来。这是一个繁忙的楼梯间。人们上上下下。而她正在经历一个人生时刻。是的。我觉得那非常有共鸣。好吧，珍娜，回到温尼伯，伙计们要到达Huntsman酒吧了。是的。我们在洛杉矶的Seven Grand酒吧和烧烤店拍摄了这些场景。你注意到在9分20秒，Huntsman的黑板上写着什么了吗？没有。这就是
it says. Welcome to the Huntsman. Enjoy, quote, pub hour all night. Sunday and Monday, 5 to 7 p.m., No creeps allowed. Oh. Oh. Get out, creeps. Get out, creeps. And I have a background catch. Again, I was hungry as I watched this episode.
它写的：“欢迎来到Huntsman。享受，引用，‘酒吧时光’整晚。周日和周一，下午5点到7点，禁止怪胎入内。”哦。哦。滚出去，怪胎。滚出去，怪胎。我有一个背景捕捉。再次，我看着这一集时饿了。
The chips. The chips, you guys. The chips that Phil Shea got are at the bar. Yes, and I think I can see the ketchup-flavored chips. They're in a red light. Ketchup flavor. Oh, yes, lady. Why did I do that with my voice?
薯片。薯片，伙计们。菲尔·谢拿到的薯片在酒吧里。是的，我想我能看到番茄酱味的薯片。它们在红色的灯光下。番茄酱味。哦，是的，女士。我为什么用那种声音说话？
Have you eaten them? Yes. I've never heard of this. item. Well, I worked in Canada for a bit, you know, and I have had these ketchup chips. Jenna, they're so good. Listen to how they're described on the internet. They're the perfect balance of a delightful old Dutch chip layered with that lovely ketchup flavor you desire. But I don't desire a ketchup flavor on my potato chips. Well, it might change your mind. I'm just telling you. Maybe I will. Chip people. Old Dutch chip people. Will you send me a ketchup chip? Oh my gosh. Get ready. But listen, make sure. some come my way. You got it. They're tangy. They're delicious. Okay. Guess who else is at the bar? Concierge Marie.
你吃过它们吗？是的。我从来没听说过这个东西。好吧，我在加拿大工作过一段时间，你知道，我吃过这些番茄酱薯片。珍娜，它们太好吃了。听听互联网上是怎么描述它们的。它们是令人愉悦的老荷兰薯片与你渴望的那种可爱的番茄酱味道的完美平衡。但我并不渴望在我的薯片上有番茄酱味。好吧，它可能会改变你的想法。我只是告诉你。也许我会的。薯片爱好者。老荷兰薯片爱好者。你会寄给我一包番茄酱薯片吗？哦，天哪。准备好。但听着，确保一些送到我这边。没问题。它们很浓郁。它们很美味。好的。猜猜酒吧里还有谁？礼宾员玛丽。
Yeah. Michael is, um, how you say, so excited to see her. Yeah. How do you say it? How do you say it? Andy's going to bring him two glasses of wine. Mm-hmm. He's going to get things started. Yeah. He's also going to try to get things started for Oscar and a couple of gentlemen sitting at a table nearby. That's right. He says to the bartender, Mademoiselle, beer me, dose Long Island Ice Tees, Cevou Play. Bad decision in a glass. It is a bad decision and a glass. It is a horrible decision. You know how you've had a volcano and you did the splits?
是的。迈克尔，嗯，怎么说呢，见到她太兴奋了。是的。你怎么说？你怎么说？安迪要给他拿两杯酒。嗯。他要开始行动了。是的。他还试图为奥斯卡和坐在附近桌子上的几位绅士开始行动。没错。他对酒保说：“Mademoiselle，给我啤酒，两杯长岛冰茶，S'il vous plaît。”杯子里的坏决定。这是一个坏决定和一杯酒。这是一个可怕的决定。你知道你曾经有过一个火山，然后你做了劈叉吗？
Yes. I had some Long Island Ice Tees. Where? In the Bahamas on spring break with my friends. I never had one before. I wasn't 21 yet, but in the Bahamas you can drink when you're 18, we went to the casino and they just give them to you free if you sit at the slot machines. I have not...
是的。我喝了一些长岛冰茶。在哪里？在巴哈马的春假期间，和我的朋友们。我以前从没喝过。我还没满21岁，但在巴哈马你可以18岁喝酒，我们去了赌场，如果你坐在老虎机旁，他们就免费给你。我没有……
All of this was like, what is happening? I have not had a Long Island iced tea. I've had the volcano, but it's just the same thing. They just dump a bunch of booze in it, right? It's like seven or eight different liquors. Tasty, went down easy. Well, yeah. Then a lot of vomiting.
所有这些就像，发生了什么？我没喝过长岛冰茶。我喝过火山，但那是一样的东西。他们只是往里面倒了一堆酒，对吧？就像七八种不同的烈酒。好喝，容易下咽。好吧，是的。然后就是大量的呕吐。
A lot of vomiting. Well, we got a fan question about this scene from Evan L. At 11 minutes, 14 seconds, Andy says, You will thank me when they spank thee. And he wants to know who came up with that line. Can I guess? Sure. Lee or Jean.
呕吐得厉害。好吧，我们收到了埃文·L关于这一幕的粉丝提问。在11分14秒，安迪说：“当你被我打屁股时，你会感谢我的。”他想知道这句台词是谁想出来的。我可以猜猜吗？当然。李或者吉恩。
That's a good guess. It's in the script and I asked Brent Forrester about it and he said he is the author of the thank me spank thee line. He said there are a few things more fun than writing a rhyming punchline for the Andy character. He said he got a little bit too into. writing rhyming punchlines for Ed that season, he said that one day in the writer's room, he pitched a line where Andy refers to his quote, backup, backup. And he said at that point, the writers forbid him from writing any more rhyming punchlines for the rest of the year.
这是个不错的猜测。这在剧本里，我问过布伦特·福雷斯特，他说他是“感谢我打屁股”这句台词的作者。他说，没有什么比为安迪这个角色写一句押韵的俏皮话更有趣的了。他说那一季他写安迪的押韵俏皮话写得有点太投入了，他说有一天在编剧室里，他提议了一句台词，安迪提到了他的“备份，备份”。他说在那之后，编剧们禁止他在这一年剩下的时间里再写任何押韵的俏皮话。
I wonder if he wrote nifty-gifties. He might have. Oh, Brent, that's so good. Well, guess what? They're not going to spank him. They turn them down. And Oscar and Andy now drink the Long Island ice teas, which is going to lead to some trouble. Some real trouble, because Oscar says to Andy, what do you see in Angela?
我想知道他有没有写过“时髦礼物”。他可能写过。哦，布伦特，那太棒了。好吧，你猜怎么着？他们不会打他屁股的。他们拒绝了。奥斯卡和安迪现在喝着长岛冰茶，这会导致一些麻烦。真正的麻烦，因为奥斯卡对安迪说，你在安吉拉身上看到了什么？
And again, I was hungry as I watched this. So at 12 minutes, 17 seconds, I can see another bag of old Dutch potato chips sitting next to Oscar's arm on the bar. They're the green and white bag. You know what that means. Sour cream and onion? They are the dill pickle chips. What? Yep. Described on the internet. Do they make any regular flavors? They do. I'm telling you, these chips are so good.
再说一次，我看这一集的时候饿了。所以在12分17秒，我可以看到另一袋老荷兰薯片放在吧台奥斯卡的胳膊旁边。那是绿白相间的袋子。你知道那意味着什么吗？酸奶油洋葱味？那是莳萝泡菜味薯片。什么？是的。网上有描述。他们做普通口味的吗？他们做。我告诉你，这些薯片太好吃了。
You've had the dill pickle ones? I have sampled. You know, like on set, we would have a whole bunch of bags of chips. They're real salty, and I liked it. I guess I'm a chip traditionalist. You know what? You need to be a chip traveler. All right. You need to try some international chips. I'll try them. Well, the dill ones are real salty. I do like a pickle. I know. But anyway, Andy drunk dials Angela. This is a huge mistake. Oh, my goodness. He says, you know what? We're going to discuss this. We will discuss this naked. But then there's a voice in the background. I mean, she's with Dwight. Of course she is. Yeah. But somehow Andy doesn't totally register it. He's had a Long Island iced tea. Several, I think, at this point. Yeah. And guess what? But Michael and concierge Marie, they're clicking. They're going to leave. They're going to smooch outside in the alley.
你吃过莳萝泡菜味的吗？我尝过。你知道，在片场，我们会有很多袋薯片。它们真的很咸，我喜欢。我想我是一个薯片传统主义者。你知道吗？你需要成为一个薯片旅行者。好吧。你需要尝试一些国际薯片。我会试试的。嗯，莳萝味的真的很咸。我确实喜欢泡菜。我知道。但不管怎样，安迪醉醺醺地给安吉拉打电话。这是一个巨大的错误。哦，天哪。他说，你知道吗？我们要讨论一下这个。我们要赤身裸体地讨论这个。但背景里有个声音。我的意思是，她和德怀特在一起。当然是她。是的。但不知何故，安迪并没有完全意识到这一点。他喝了一杯长岛冰茶。我想此时已经喝了好几杯了。是的。而且你猜怎么着？迈克尔和礼宾员玛丽，他们很合拍。他们要离开了。他们要在外面的小巷里亲热。
And we asked Wendy about this, about kissing Steve. And here's what she had to say. I was super nervous to kiss Steve Correll. I was so nervous that I was practically going into convulsions. But I did it, and it was great. And I highly recommend it. She highly recommends. Oh, well, they're not just going to kiss outside the hotel.
我们问过温迪关于这件事，关于亲吻史蒂夫。这是她要说的。我亲吻史蒂夫·卡瑞尔时超级紧张。我紧张得几乎要抽搐了。但我还是做了，感觉很棒。我强烈推荐。她强烈推荐。哦，好吧，他们不仅仅是在酒店外面接吻。
All right. We are going to cut to Michael being sort of shoved out of her. Room 887. Yeah, without his shoes. Barefoot, he's shuffling down the hall. I know. And then she's like, wait, you forgot your shoes. Only she says nothing.
好吧。我们要切到迈克尔被赶出她的房间，887号房。是的，没穿鞋。赤着脚，他在走廊里拖着步子走。我知道。然后她就像是，等等，你忘了你的鞋子了。只是她什么也没说。
She just sets them out and quickly shuts the door. Well, that kind of wraps up concierge Marie. We had to ask Wendy if she. if she ever gets recognized for being on the show. And here's what she said. Yes, so many times. I'm so surprised at that because I was, you know, barely in it. But, you know, that just speaks to the reach and the popularity of the office.
她只是把鞋子放出来，然后迅速关上了门。好吧，这算是结束了礼宾员玛丽的戏份。我们不得不问温迪她是否因为出演这部剧而被认出来。这是她说的。是的，很多次。我对此感到非常惊讶，因为你知道，我几乎没怎么出镜。但是，你知道，这正说明了《办公室》的影响力和受欢迎程度。
I read a fun fact about Wendy. Yes, you did. Share it, Jenna. It's so good. Okay. Wendy was the editor for California State University's Academic Journal of Social Work. This was her day job before she hit it big as an actress. But even after she was working all the time, she kept her job until 2012.
我读过一个关于温迪的趣事。是的，你读过。分享一下吧，珍娜。太棒了。好的。温迪曾是加州州立大学《社会工作学术期刊》的编辑。这是她在成为大明星之前的日常工作。但即使在她工作非常忙碌之后，她还是保留了这份工作直到2012年。
Bridesmaids came out in 2011. So even after bridesmaids, she was still editing this journal of social work. And we had to ask her about it. Here's what she said. It is true that while I was building my acting career and, you know, doing pretty well, that I kept my side job at Cal State Long Beach. I was an assistant editor for a social work journal. I did that for 12 years, all through Reno 911, all through, you know, all these movies
《伴娘》是2011年上映的。所以即使在《伴娘》之后，她还在编辑这本社会工作期刊。我们不得不问她这件事。这是她说的。确实，当我在建立我的演艺事业，并且做得还不错的时候，我保留了我在加州州立大学长滩分校的副业。我是社会工作期刊的助理编辑。我做了12年，贯穿了《雷诺911》，贯穿了所有这些电影
that I did, rules of engagement, and right up until the Goldbergs. And the only reason I'm not doing it anymore is because the journal folded. It went out of business. But it was a great job. It was like not even 20 hours a week. I could do it from wherever I was, and it was all about, you know, people in the social work profession. And let's be honest, those people deserve a lot of credit for what they do.
我拍的那些，比如《婚前试爱》，一直到《戈德堡一家》。我不再做这份工作的唯一原因是期刊停刊了。它倒闭了。但这是一份很棒的工作。每周甚至不到20个小时。我可以在任何地方完成它，而且它都是关于社会工作专业人士的。老实说，这些人所做的工作值得很多赞扬。
They don't get recognized enough. Yeah, it was great. And I loved doing it. I loved my original boss who used to come and see my shows at the groundlings. Like, she was just so super supportive that she said, please don't ever quit. So I kept my word and I stayed until the very end. See what I was saying about amazing human being? I love her.
他们没有得到足够的认可。是的，这很棒。我喜欢做这份工作。我喜欢我原来的老板，她过去常来看我在Groundlings的演出。她非常支持我，她说，请永远不要辞职。所以我信守诺言，一直坚持到最后。看到我说的关于了不起的人类了吗？我爱她。
You know, that was so moving to me when I heard it. My niece is a social worker. I'm just always, you know, honestly, guys, I'm lifting her up in prayer all the time because it's not an easy job. And I'm thankful that we have people that have a passion for helping others in that way. Yeah, it's not an easy job because sometimes you have to see and confront real hard things. Yes. And then you have to hold that. Yeah.
你知道，当我听到这个的时候，我非常感动。我的侄女是一名社会工作者。我总是，老实说，伙计们，我一直在为她祈祷，因为这不是一份容易的工作。我很感激我们有这样一群热衷于以这种方式帮助他人的人。是的，这不是一份容易的工作，因为有时你必须看到并面对非常艰难的事情。是的。然后你必须承受这些。是的。
Yeah. Well, as if you needed another reason to love Wendy, I would also like to share that in 2009, 2010, and 2011, she rang in the new year performing at military bases in Iraq and Kuwait. And she went to the smaller bases that a lot of people didn't go to that kind of rarely get entertainment. Love that. Love you. Wendy, thank you so much. It was so great to reconnect with you. Thanks for sharing your memories of the office. You guys, you can find Wendy in so many places. She's so talented. She has a podcast called Generation Ripe.
是的。好吧，如果你还需要另一个爱温迪的理由，我还想分享的是，在2009年、2010年和2011年，她是在伊拉克和科威特的军事基地表演中迎接新年的。她去了很多很少有人去、几乎没有娱乐活动的较小基地。喜欢这个。爱你。温迪，非常感谢。能和你重新联系真是太好了。感谢你分享你在《办公室》的回忆。伙计们，你们可以在很多地方找到温迪。她非常有才华。她有一个播客叫《Generation Ripe》。
It is for teenagers over 40. It's described as a Generation Ripe listener is someone who thinks of their age as an asset, not a liability. We are older people with young souls or younger people with old souls. Of course, she's on the Goldbergs. They're about to start season nine. She's on a Marvel series on Hulu called Modak. and just tons of other things, you guys. And you can find her on Instagram at Wendy McClendon Covey.
它是为40岁以上的青少年准备的。它的描述是：Generation Ripe的听众是那些把年龄视为资产而不是负担的人。我们是拥有年轻灵魂的老年人，或者是拥有老灵魂的年轻人。当然，她在《戈德堡一家》里。他们即将开始第九季。她在Hulu的一部漫威系列剧《魔多客》里。还有很多其他的东西，伙计们。你们可以在Instagram上找到她，账号是Wendy McClendon Covey。
Yes. Let's see. Where should we go? It's the next day. Ooh, people are hungover. Very hungover. Andy does not remember calling Angela. I know.
是的。让我们看看。我们该去哪儿？第二天了。哦，人们宿醉了。宿醉得很厉害。安迪不记得给安吉拉打过电话。我知道。
Oh, no. Oh. Michael is very melancholy. Yeah. And he has to go sell paper at Catalyst Paper. Which I looked it up. Yeah. It's a real Canadian paper company, but it looks like its headquarters is based in Richmond, British Columbia, which is over on the West Coast.
哦，不。哦。迈克尔非常忧郁。是的。他必须去Catalyst Paper卖纸。我查了一下。是的。这是一家真正的加拿大造纸公司，但看起来它的总部位于不列颠哥伦比亚省的列治文，也就是西海岸那边。
I could not find a Winnipeg branch. I mean, if you couldn't, I doubt it's there. David Wallace calls to congratulate Michael because he did it. He got the sale. Michael is mad. Yeah, because he's realized that this trip was a band-aid to try to help his feelings. about Holly being transferred, he's upset. And he tells him off.
我找不到温尼伯的分公司。我的意思是，如果你找不到，我怀疑它根本不存在。大卫·华莱士打电话祝贺迈克尔，因为他做到了。他完成了销售。迈克尔很生气。是的，因为他意识到这次旅行只是为了缓解他关于霍莉被调走的情绪的创可贴，他很心烦。他斥责了他。
Yeah. I have a location breakdown. Why do you say it like that? I don't know. You said it like SADC. You said it like this. I have a location breakdown. Well, I'm sad with Michael.
是的。我有一个地点细分。你为什么那样说？我不知道。你说的就像SADC。你是这样说的。我有一个地点细分。好吧，我和迈克尔一样难过。
Aw. Yeah. For the Winnipeg Airport for these scenes, we used Terminal Number 2 at L.A.X. Randy let me know that there was an area that was out of service at that time. and that our location manager, Kyle Alexander, was able to get an agreement from the LAX airport to let us film there. That's like unheard of. Well, LAX does not let you film. Like, they are hardcore.
噢。是的。对于温尼伯机场的这些场景，我们使用了洛杉矶国际机场的2号航站楼。兰迪告诉我，当时有一个区域是停止服务的。我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大能够从洛杉矶国际机场获得协议，让我们在那里拍摄。这简直是闻所未闻。好吧，洛杉矶国际机场不让你拍摄。他们非常强硬。
Well, especially after 9-11, they had incredibly strict airport security. So we were only allowed a very small number of cast and crew and extras. Everybody had to submit credentials very far in advance and had to be screened. Yeah. So he said they had to create what they called a micro unit. That's how small it was. He said that the airplanes outside the window were not Air Canada planes. They had to paint over the logos using visual effects during post-production. And so they put the red maple leaf on the tail of one of the planes. We could only afford to do one plane. If you look over Michael's shoulder, it's on the left. Yeah, I saw it. Well, before we get to this big business with Jim and Pam, we should probably let you know that Kelly is going to break up with Daryl. I mean, Ryan has a text ready to go. They just have to hit Sin together. And I think, what is Ryan want? Does he want Daryl to come upstairs and make a scene? What does Ryan want? He wants to be the other guy. Yeah, he wants a reaction out of Daryl. Daryl seems relieved. He's whistling as he walks to his car. He responds immediately, okay, cool.
嗯，特别是在9-11之后，他们有极其严格的机场安检。所以我们只被允许带极少数的演员、工作人员和临时演员。每个人都必须提前很久提交证件并接受审查。是的。所以他说他们必须创建一个所谓的“微型单元”。就是那么小。他说窗外的飞机不是加拿大航空公司的飞机。他们必须在后期制作中使用视觉效果覆盖标志。所以他们在其中一架飞机的尾部放上了红枫叶。我们只能负担得起做一架飞机。如果你看迈克尔的肩膀上方，它在左边。是的，我看到了。好吧，在我们处理吉姆和帕姆的这件大事之前，我们应该让你知道凯利要和达里尔分手了。我的意思是，瑞恩已经准备好了一条短信。他们只需要一起按下发送键。我想，瑞恩想要什么？他想让达里尔上楼来闹事吗？瑞恩想要什么？他想成为那个“第三者”。是的，他想从达里尔那里得到反应。达里尔似乎松了一口气。他走回车里时在吹口哨。他立即回应，好的，酷。
And then literally is like doing a dance to his pickup truck. Yeah. He's like, whew. Thank you, Ryan. And that then, of course, immediately makes Ryan less interested in this relationship. And here we go. Here we go. All right.
然后真的就像是在跳着舞走向他的皮卡车。是的。他就像是，呼。谢谢你，瑞恩。然后这当然立即让瑞恩对这段关系失去了兴趣。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。好吧。
Jim is going to leave. And again, you guys have this Jim and Pam scene at that golden hour. Your hair is sparkling with sunshine. It's like that sunset scene in the parking lot. you couldn't look cuter. I know. I thought this scene was really sweet. Yeah, Pam is standing in the parking lot and Jim says, what are you doing here? Because he had told her on the phone, when you come back, you're going to come back the right way. Right. And he's supportive. If she wants to take the class again, they'll get through it. Yes, that the right way to come back is for her to come back having graduated from art school. So Pam's standing there and she says, I'm coming back the wrong way. But she's okay with it. She's happy about it. She missed Scranton. She missed Jim. She actually hated the graphic design school. Yeah. She tells Jim, this isn't really what I wanted to do. But she had to go to find that out. She did. You know, we had a question from Evan L. Why did the writers have Pam fail art school? Well, that's a good question, Evan. I asked Brent Forrester about it. He said that the story of Pam's, failing art school and coming back, quote, the wrong way was a pitch from Jen Salada. Brent said, I have a daughter, and he said, I'm a big fat feminist, that's a quote.
吉姆要离开了。再说一次，你们在那个黄金时刻有这个吉姆和帕姆的场景。你的头发在阳光下闪闪发光。就像停车场里的那个日落场景。你看起来可爱极了。我知道。我觉得这一幕真的很甜。是的，帕姆站在停车场，吉姆说，你在这里做什么？因为他在电话里告诉过她，当你回来的时候，你要以正确的方式回来。对。而且他很支持。如果她想再上这门课，他们会挺过去的。是的，回来的正确方式是她从艺术学校毕业后回来。所以帕姆站在那里，她说，我以错误的方式回来了。但她对此没问题。她对此感到高兴。她想念斯克兰顿。她想念吉姆。她其实讨厌那所平面设计学校。是的。她告诉吉姆，这不是我真正想做的事情。但她必须去才能发现这一点。她确实去了。你知道，我们收到了埃文·L的一个问题。为什么编剧让帕姆从艺术学校退学？好吧，这是一个好问题，埃文。我问过布伦特·福雷斯特。他说帕姆从艺术学校退学并以“错误的方式”回来的故事是珍·萨拉达提出的。布伦特说，我有一个女儿，他说，我是一个大胖女权主义者，这是原话。
And the idea that Pam would give up on her dreams to be with a man really rubbed him the wrong way, but that Jen Salada absolutely insisted that the romantic power of this gesture outweighed any politics. and also that the truth for Pam was not that she was giving up on her dreams for Jim, but that she was distinguishing what her real dreams were. And I really liked that because I think what Pam did here in going to graphic design school was that she was taking her real dream of being a creative artist, and she was doing what a lot of artists do, and she was trying to find a practical application.
帕姆为了和一个男人在一起而放弃梦想的想法让他非常不舒服，但珍·萨拉达坚决认为这种姿态的浪漫力量超过了任何政治。而且对帕姆来说，真相并不是她为了吉姆放弃了梦想，而是她在区分她真正的梦想是什么。我真的很喜欢这一点，因为我认为帕姆在这里去平面设计学校所做的是，她正在追求她作为创意艺术家的真正梦想，她正在做很多艺术家都会做的事情，她正在尝试寻找一种实际的应用。
Right. How can I sort of do art but make a living? Yeah. Right? Yes. Exactly. But, you know, I mean, people go into graphic design when they're passionate about graphic design. It's not some backup job, right?
对。我怎样才能在做艺术的同时谋生？对吧？是的。完全正确。但是，你知道，我的意思是，当人们对平面设计充满热情时，他们才会进入平面设计领域。这不是什么备用工作，对吧？
And the truth is, is that Pam discovered she does not have a passion for graphic design. And that's sort of what I had in my head when I was doing that scene on the phone with Jim and Pam's crying. Pam is realizing that even if she's. she did pass the course, this isn't for her. But she's also embarrassed that she failed. But what she definitely does not want to do is spend 12 more weeks studying something she doesn't love. For me, in that moment, I just saw Pam stating her truth. And I always think that's so powerful. Yeah. There is a very sweet deleted scene, you guys, with Jim and Pam. It's in the break room. And you know what? I'm titling it.
事实是，帕姆发现她对平面设计没有热情。这就是我在和吉姆通电话、帕姆哭泣时脑子里想的事情。帕姆意识到即使她通过了这门课程，这也不适合她。但她也为自己失败感到尴尬。但她绝对不想再花12周时间学习她不爱的东西。对我来说，在那一刻，我只是看到帕姆在陈述她的真相。我一直认为这非常有力量。是的。有一个非常甜蜜的删减片段，伙计们，关于吉姆和帕姆。它在休息室里。你知道吗？我给它起个标题。
What? Love in the break room. What is it? Pam is showing Jim her art assignment. She has this portfolio and she's showing him the piece that she got an F on. Oh, I remember shooting this now. Yes. Yes.
什么？休息室里的爱。是什么？帕姆正在给吉姆看她的艺术作业。她有这个作品集，她正在给他看那件她得了F的作品。哦，我现在记得拍这一幕了。是的。是的。
Oh, I remember it. It's really sweet. And as he goes through her art assignments in the back, tucked in the binder is a sketch pad. And he's like, what is this? And she said, oh, you know, it's just sketches of things I would see in New York. And when you look at them, Jenna, and I'll put it in stories. It's like people sitting at a cafe, things she might have seen on her walk. And they're really good.
哦，我记得。真的很甜。当他翻看她背后的艺术作业时，夹在活页夹里的是一本素描本。他就像，这是什么？她说，哦，你知道，这只是我在纽约看到的东西的素描。当你看着它们时，珍娜，我会把它们放在故事里。就像人们坐在咖啡馆里，她在散步时可能看到的东西。它们真的很好。
And this is such a wonderful moment. I wish it had stayed in. Sam, can you play the clip? This is my project. Before we start, how did you fail? You're good at art. See? Yeah.
这是一个如此美妙的时刻。我希望它能保留下来。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？这是我的项目。在我们开始之前，你是怎么挂科的？你很擅长艺术。看？是的。
We had to make a logo for a coffee company. Well, that's nice. This is the one that got an A. The teacher handed it out. And this is mine. Well, that's cool. I couldn't get it to print out right, so I got an F. I would have given you a D.
我们必须为一家咖啡公司制作一个标志。嗯，那很好。这是得A的那一个。老师把它发下来了。这是我的。嗯，那很酷。我没能把它打印出来，所以我得了个F。我会给你一个D。
That's only because we're sleeping with a professor. These are cool. What's this? That's my sketchbook. It's just, you know, stuff I saw New York, people on the subway. Whoa. This is great.
那只是因为我们和教授睡了。这些很酷。这是什么？那是我的素描本。这只是，你知道，我在纽约看到的东西，地铁上的人。哇。这太棒了。
It's so much different than your other work. Wow, Pam. That is awesome. Yeah? Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I wish that had stayed in. It's a really sweet scene, and I feel like it just shows what Pam did get out of New York.
它和你其他的作品很不一样。哇，帕姆。那太棒了。是吗？是啊。是啊。哦，我希望它能保留下来。这是一个非常甜蜜的场景，我觉得它展示了帕姆从纽约得到了什么。
And I really wish it had been in the episode. I agree, because I don't think Pam's art story is over yet. Mm-hmm. You know, she did not have the benefit of, I think, parents or role models who encouraged her to follow this piece of herself. And she only finally does now have that person in Jim. So she's going to have to take her art journey at the same time as her romantic journey. Well, I'm going to put that scene in stories because it's really sweet. I loved it.
我真的很希望它能出现在这一集中。我同意，因为我不认为帕姆的艺术故事已经结束了。嗯哼。你知道，我认为她没有得到鼓励她追随自己这一面的父母或榜样的支持。她现在终于在吉姆身上有了那个人。所以她必须在进行浪漫旅程的同时进行她的艺术旅程。好吧，我会把那个场景放在故事里，因为它真的很甜。我喜欢它。
I did too. Well, that kind of wraps up this episode. Yeah. Thank you to everyone who helped us make this episode. Brent Forrester, Randy Cordray, Wendy McClendon Covey, and Rich Summer. Thanks for coming on for an interview. It takes a village. It does.
我也喜欢。好吧，这算是结束了这一集。是的。感谢所有帮助我们制作这一集的人。布伦特·福雷斯特、兰迪·科德雷、温迪·麦克伦登-考维和里奇·萨默。感谢你们来接受采访。这需要一个村庄。确实。
And thank you to you guys for sending in awesome questions and Winnipeg trivia. Yes. Some last parting advice. According to Andy, Long Island iced teas are way stronger in Canada. So be careful the next time you order one of those. Yes. All right, you guys. Well, that was business trip and we will be seeing you next week.
也感谢你们发送了很棒的问题和温尼伯的琐事。是的。最后的一些建议。根据安迪的说法，长岛冰茶在加拿大要浓得多。所以下次你点的时候要小心。是的。好吧，伙计们。好吧，那是商务旅行，我们下周见。
Yeah, see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our second drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
是的，下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的“第二杯”。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的“第二杯”剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。